Ja, da bin ich wieder, stellt euch das mal vor und ich habe heute eine neue Tee-Sorte
am Start und zwar trinke ich heute Leute, Zauber der Zwerge, ich weiß nicht warum das
so heißt, weil von Zwergen schmecke ich nichts, aber es war ein bisschen was anderes, Zauber
der Zwerge.
Okay, also ich erzähle euch mal was wir heute machen, das ist eigentlich ganz einfach was
wir heute machen.
Wir gucken uns jetzt erstmal, so eine Stunde würde ich sagen, muss ich mich noch ein bisschen
ausruhen.
Okay, ähm, was zum, okay, also, genau, das ist eigentlich ganz einfach was wir heute
machen.
So eine Stunde, muss ich mich wie gesagt noch ein bisschen ausruhen, wir gucken uns das
Deckoverflow-Survey an, 2022, so meistgeliebte Technologien, meistgehasste Technologien,
Frontend-Frameworks, Backend-Technologie, was auch immer, was die da halt so für Umfragen
haben, so, was haben die sonst noch, so beliebteste Programmiersprachen und sowas in der Richtung.
Gucken wir uns an, dann gucken wir uns vielleicht ein, zwei Videos kurz an und dann spielen
wir tatsächlich nochmal ein paar Runden Battlefield 2042 im Anschluss.
Da isst mir es heute irgendwie danach, aber ich muss mich erstmal eine Stunde ein bisschen
ausruhen.
Also ich denk mal so, so bis 20 Uhr oder so machen wir ein bisschen, bisschen ein Spannungsprogramm
und dann machen wir noch zwei Stunden Battlefield und vielleicht fangen wir auch schon ein bisschen
früher mit Battlefield an, aber ich will mir auf jeden Fall heute das Stack, die Stackoverflow-Umfrage
2023 angucken.
Tü-dü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü.
Vielleicht soll ich das sogar in, in Titel vom Streamer Stackoverflow-Survey-2300 ist
da.
Habe mal einen Titel, kann man da ein bisschen Werbung für machen.
Wollen sich bestimmt noch mehr angucken.
Ja, also so wie das Ganze heute ausschauen, jepp-wurst, so wir das heute machen.
Also wir gucken uns die Stackoverflow-Umfrage angucken und dann vielleicht ein, zwei Videos
an.
Mir wurde vorhin ein interessantes Video empfohlen, zumindest vom Titel her, ich habe das noch
nicht geguckt und zwar Gen Z hat keinen Bock auf Arbeitszeit 9 bis 5, äh 9 bis 17 Uhr.
Und da würde ich so pauschal sagen, die Gen Z hat recht.
Wann gab es denn Gen Z, Jahrgang, wann ist denn das, wann ist das schon?
Ja okay und was ist jetzt Generation A oder was, was kommt, was kommt nach Gen Z eigentlich?
What's after, geht wieder von vorne los, kek, das ist ja langweilig.
Warum geht das wieder von vorne los?
Machen die alle, keine Ahnung, 300 Jahre oder so, rotieren die dann?
Das ist ja doof, ich dachte die, die, die machen da jetzt irgendwie sowas wie Generation,
keine Ahnung, die machen mit einem anderen Alphabet weiter oder so, aber das ist ja schwierig,
weil da gibt es wieder so viele Noobs, die das nicht wissen, wie man es auf der Tastatur
tippt.
Ja, wie gesagt, wusste ich nicht, dass das dann als nächstes kommt.
Na gut, Leute, ihr werdet es nicht glauben, was heute auf der Arbeit passiert ist.
Wer mir auf Twitter folgt, wird es schon gesehen haben und zwar, jetzt könnt ihr mal kekken
eine Runde.
Diese Message habe ich heute bekommen in Teams, noch mehr und ich habe dann auch darauf geantwortet,
das habe ich euch natürlich nicht gescreenshottet, nur die erste Message liegt, ja, das war heut,
das war heute Mittag.
Wir hatten heute Mittag so eine Vorstellungsrunde, wo drei Leute was präsentiert haben, ich
habe nichts präsentiert, ich habe danach eine Frage gestellt, warum nicht im Darkroom,
das ist ja eine berechtigte Frage, hast du schon recht, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht.
Ja, zumindest habe ich das dann heute gekriegt und ich habe zugegeben, dass ich das bin.
So, und heute Mittag, irgendwann 14 Uhr oder so, hat mich noch einer angeschrieben, ob
ich MaxFPS von YouTube bin.
Ich glaube, es wissen jetzt insgesamt so 5 oder 6 Leute bei mir auf der Arbeit, die
haben das alle irgendwie direkt gecheckt, erstes Meeting, wo ich drin war, bam, kann es sein,
dass du der Max von YouTube bist?
Ich rede mich da gar nicht raus, ich sage halt, ich bin's, ich meine, die Leute sind nicht
doof.
Ja, hab ich doch geschrieben, Leute sind blöd, das ist offensichtlich.
Ich habe da sogar mein Headset auf, was ihr hier jetzt schon gesehen habt, das mit diesem
Schwamm vorne drauf als Popschutz, ich habe ja keinen normalen Popschutz mehr auf meinem
MMX300, also ich habe ja hier dieses Ding hier als Headset, schon ewig, schon 12 Jahre
oder so, das ist wirklich alt und der normale Popschutz ist schon lange kaputt und ich hatte
mir einen Ersatz-Popschutz gekauft, aber ganz ehrlich, diese Popschutz hier, die sind alle
nicht gut, da hat man immer noch so ziemlich nervige Geräusche, Teilweise, und ich habe
jetzt einen Schwamm gekauft, wo man normalerweise sein Auto mit wascht und ich habe den Schwamm
quasi so rund geschnitten und dann über das Mikrofon gezogen und seitdem, und hinten habe
ich einen Kabelbinder drum gemacht, seitdem, alles gelber Popschutz, genau, und das sorgt
auch jedes Mal, wenn Leute noch nicht mit mir im Meeting waren, immer für lustige Fragen
und blöde Sprüche, da kommen die Leute, Max, du hast da eine Kartoffel im Gesicht,
ha, null, oder sowas in der Richtung, ja, gibt es immer Leute, die wollen dann furchtbar
lustig sein, ich kenne ja die ganzen Sprüche schon, weil ich mir schon tausendmal anhören
müsste, aber es stört mich nicht weiter, dafür habe ich guten Sound, was die meisten
Leute nicht sagen können über sich im Homeoffice, welches Audiointerface ich benutze, ich benutze
eine Kombination, ich habe einen Mototrack 16, das habe ich auch schon ganz lang, ja,
seit 2013, 14, 14 oder so irgendwie in dem Dreh, das hat sogar noch Firewire, aber ich
habe es natürlich per USB angeschlossen, das habe ich, das gibt es mit so einem, das
gibt es mit so einem Extension, Extensionkabel, wo man dann alle möglichen Anschlüsse hinten
hat, also das, das habe ich und ich habe noch so ein billiges Behringer Mischding, das benutze
ich beispielsweise auch, da sind die Konsolen dran, dass ich dann darüber auch das Audio,
falls ich jemals Konsole wieder spiele, das Audio auf den richtigen Output kriege und
sowas, ja, das ist die Kombination, so sieht es aus, ne, das hat noch keiner gesagt, das
spricht auf der Arbeit auch keiner an, ich meine, das weiß doch auch gar keiner, dass
ich nur vier Tage arbeite, das wissen die Leute in meinem Team, der Rest, der kriegt
das doch gar nicht so mit, die denken halt, ok, der ist halt heute nicht da, so, kommt
halt vor, next, das juckt die gar nicht großartig, ja, ok, dann gucken wir uns mal die Stackoverflow-Umfrage
an, also das haben wir hier am Start, ich glaube, ich glaube, zehn Minuten hat der Stream
jetzt Zeit anzulaufen, ich denke, das passt schon, habt ihr die letzten Tage über so
ein bisschen die Presentations verfolgt, ich habe mir die Xbox, war das, ja, Xbox habe
ich mir ein bisschen angeguckt und ich muss sagen, es kommen verhältnismäßig viele
Games raus in nächster Zeit und nachdem Microsoft das gescheit macht, so nach dem
Motto, Release eigentlich so gut wie immer, Xbox und PC, ist da vielleicht das ein oder
andere dabei, also Ubisoft war nix, Ubisoft habe ich auch geguckt, wisst ihr, was das
beste bei der Ubisoft-Präsentation war, ohne Scheiß, Chetke, wer von euch hat die Ubisoft-Präsentation
gesehen, das, das beste, ne, weißt du, was das beste bei der Ubisoft-Präsentation war,
der Pirate-Song, diese Band, die sie da hatten, die irgendeinen Piraten-Song gespielt hat,
das war eigentlich das beste an der ganzen Ubisoft-Präsentation, ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass für irgendwelche Star Wars-Fans das Star Wars-Spiel am Ende noch ganz nice war, aber
juckt mich, juckt mich nicht großartig, die hast du geskippt, der Pirate-Song war eigentlich
das beste an der ganzen Präsentation, der Rest, der war nix, wieso so viele, wie viele
RAMs, ne, weil ich mein RAM irgendwie, wieso, wieso so viele Tabs, weil ich mein RAM voll
kriegen muss, du wirst nicht, was meinst du denn, Yoga Kumi, was meinst du, wie viel RAM
das verbraucht, ich, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass du dich, dass du mehr denkst, als es
wirklich ist, das verbraucht nämlich gar nicht so viel RAM, guck mal, 20G, schön wärs,
guck mal, nix verbrauchtes, ich hab jetzt nur 15G RAM verbraucht und das liegt aber zum
größten Teil daran, weil ich doch auf nem anderen Account eingeloggt bin und da ne VM
laufen hab, sonst wären wir irgendwie bei, keine Ahnung, 8, 9 MB, äh, 8, 9G, das ist
ja nix, guck mal, ich mein, ich hab 64G, das hab ich mir komplett umsonst gekauft, 64G
übertakteter RGB RAM und, und nix wird benutzt, rausgeschmissenes Geld, ne, das hat, glaube
ich, keiner von Microsoft gesagt, es wird ihm nur nachgesagt, es wird Bill Gates, glaube
ich, nachgesagt, dass er mal erzählt hat, dass er angeblich mal gesagt hat, mehr als
384 KB oder so braucht niemand, das hat er aber wohl nie gesagt, oh, was ist denn das,
oh ne, please, kein Windows Neustart, hör mir bloß auf, ich hoffe, ich darf den Neustart
verschieben, ja, also, schauen wir uns mal die Stack Overflow Umfrage 2023 an, die machen
ja jedes Jahr sowas und da gibt's Umfragen zum Thema, ah, okay, ja, da gibt's Umfragen,
wie Leute was gelernt haben, äh, populäre Technologien, gesuchte Technologien, was die
Leute haben wollen, was begehrt ist und Zeug, das ist eigentlich immer ganz aufschlussreich,
wenn auch insgesamt, würde ich sagen, vielleicht, ich meine, das ist eine Umfrage, da kann jeder
mitmachen, das ist jetzt nichts, was nur für Kokona ist, aber ich hab den Eindruck, es
ist ein bisschen US gefärbt immer, das Ganze, aber im Großen und Ganzen finde ich das jedes
Jahr immer recht aufschlussreich, deswegen, wir gucken uns, wir haben uns das letztes
Jahr angeguckt, ich glaube, wir haben uns das, glaube ich, jedes Jahr bisher angeguckt, seitdem
ich streame, wieso nutzen eigentlich so viele Chromium, äh, weil, es gibt ja nicht wirklich
viele Browser, was für Browser kannst du benutzen, du kannst auf dem Desktop Chrome oder Firefox
benutzen, okay, okay, es gibt Leute, die benutzen Safari, aber den ist ja, außer Mac-User, aber
den ist ja echt nicht mehr zu helfen, also, Brave ist auch Chrome, von der, von der Rendering
Engine und allem her, der Rest ist ja alles nur ein bisschen Kosmetik drumherum und paar,
gerade, der, okay, auf dem Desktop gibt es noch ein paar Zusatzfunktionen, im Prinzip
gibt es Chrome und Firefox und Firefox ist eher so ein bisschen für, zumindest war es
das eigentlich, immer so ein bisschen für ein Plugin orientierte Technik interessierte,
wobei selbst dort, würde ich sagen, hat Mozilla ein bisschen Programm gegen die eigentliche
Zielgruppe gemacht, die letzten Jahre über, das heißt, im Endeffekt, viele Leute sind
einfach auf Chrome hängen geblieben, weil es so die, wie sagt man, sensible default
einfach ist, das ist irgendwie sowas naheliegendes Standardprogramm, wobei ich ja auch nicht Chrome
benutze, sondern Chromium, das heißt, ich habe ein paar weniger Google-Geschichten mit
dabei, aber ich habe Chromium auf, Chrome und oftmals habe ich auch noch im Stream irgendwie
einen Firefox oder so da noch auf, also, es ist, unter Linux benutze ich übrigens nur
Firefox oder fast nur Firefox, nicht nur ich, ich habe auch Chrome installiert und manchmal
mit offen, aber Linux benutze ich 95% Firefox, unter Windows benutze ich tatsächlich alle
drei Browser, ich benutze Chromium, ich benutze, also ich benutze, ich kann es euch noch sagen,
ich benutze Chromium eigentlich so für die tägliche, tägliche Sache, die ich mache
am Computer, benutze ich Chromium für, zum Arbeiten und alle möglichen Sachen, die damit
zu tun haben und für DRM-geschützte Sachen benutze ich Chrome und für YouTube und Influencer-Shit
benutze ich Firefox, da ist das, da ist das auch alles logisch irgendwie ein bisschen
getrennt, finde ich ganz angenehm, so mache ich das, Vivaldi ist auch Chromium, richtig,
Vivaldi finde ich aber eigentlich von der Idee her ganz gut, Vivaldi ist von den ehemaligen
Opera-Entwicklern, wenn ich das jetzt nicht ganz, doch, glaub schon, dass das so war und
die haben halt sehr viel Zeug noch dabei gestrickt, wenn man diese Funktion mag, ist das sicherlich
ganz nice, aber, also ich find's cool, aber ich weiß nicht, nicht das, was ich tagtäglich
benutzen will, ja, deswegen bin ich halt jetzt so ein bisschen auf Chromium unter Windows
hängen geblieben und unter Linux auch teilweise, aber unter Linux hauptsächlich Firefox.
Du musst dein Arsch Linux formatieren, weil ich so dumm war und falsche Grafik treibe,
ich hab Neustart, Black Screen, jetzt wieder Windows App.
Du kannst Black Screen, du kannst einfach in eine Shell booten, du musst keine grafische
Oberfläche starten, aber das ist halt unter Linux teilweise ein bisschen schwierig, wenn
man sich damit nicht so auskennt, das verstehe ich auch, das passiert unter Windows glücklicherweise
selten, wobei man sagen muss, auch unter Linux selten, aber unter Windows passiert es tatsächlich
so gut wie nie.
Im Zweifelsfall lädt Windows irgendeinen Backup-Grafiktreiber, also ein, in wie auch
immer geartetes Bild kriegst du bei Windows eigentlich immer, sei denn es crasht direkt.
So, also, gucken wir uns das Ganze mal an, Chat, also Plan für heute, hab ich am Anfang
schon gesagt, aber da waren noch nicht so viele Leute da, Plan für heute ist folgendes,
wir gucken uns jetzt die nächste Stunde, so bis 8, wir gucken uns das Stackoverflow-Survey
an, äh, die Stackoverflow-Umfrage an, ich geb mal ein Senf dazu, wir gucken vielleicht
noch ein Video, was mir vorher empfohlen wurde, das klang ganz gut, das Beispiel, dass die
Generation Z kein Bock mehr hat, 9 to 5 zu arbeiten, was ich auch komplett verstehen
kann, mal gucken, ob das was taugt, wenn nicht, machen wir das aus, und dann spielen wir heute
noch zwei Runden Battlefield, irgendwie hab ich Bock, noch ein paar Runden Battlefield
zu spielen, außerdem muss ich mal ein Video drüber aufnehmen, ob sich das jetzt aktuell
lohnt oder nicht, weil das irgendwie die meistgestellte Frage in Battlefield-Streams immer, oh ne,
es lohnt sich nicht, neu zum Vollpreis zu kaufen, also, gibt eine neue Stackoverflow-Umfrage,
wir fangen, wir fangen einfach oben an, und gehen da so durch, also, was haben wir denn,
Educa-, ne, ehrlich gesagt, juckt mich das nicht, Education, Learning to Code, ganz ehrlich,
mich interessieren Technologies, what the fuck, da geht's aber gar nicht los, ok, komm,
scheiß drauf, scheiß drauf, wir fangen doch oben an, also, was haben wir denn jetzt, Education,
also wo haben die Leute programmieren gelernt, zum Beispiel, ok, in der Schule so gut wie
gar keiner, Professional Developers, Learning to Code, ok, alle zusammen, also in der Schule
hat so gut wie gar keiner programmieren gelernt, das wundert mich nicht, bei uns in der Schule
gab's sowas auch nicht, oder in der Realschule, ok, tatsächlich, das wundert mich jetzt, dass
so viele Leute in der Realschule oder in der Highschool oder sowas in der Richtung tatsächlich
schon mal Kontakt mit Programmieren bekommen haben, hätte ich gar nicht gedacht, dass man's
in der Grundschule nicht hat, das ist eigentlich relativ klar, weil in der Grundschule macht
man kein Programmieren, aber 10%, ohne Mist, 10% in der Schule ist gar nicht mal so übel,
ok, studiert, Uni, sonst was, bla bla bla bla, ja gut, die meisten haben, die meisten haben,
wenn sie studieren, die meisten haben, wenn sie studieren, gerade wenn sie Informatik studieren
oder sagen wir irgendwas Technisches, haben sie dort Programmieren gelernt, ja gut, ich glaube,
dass das auch tatsächlich, ich denke, dass es sehr repräsentativ auch so durchschnittmäßig,
ich glaube, das trifft auf die meisten zu, wobei ich persönlich die Erfahrung gemacht habe,
dass bei Entwicklern und bei Entwicklern, von denen ich denke, Alter, die haben wirklich richtig Plan
und die atmen das quasi so, die leben das so komplett, bei denen habe ich den Eindruck, dort
haben zwar viele so richtig auch beim Studium gelernt, wenn sie studiert haben, auch zum ersten
Mal so richtig professionell angewendet und mit anderen zusammengearbeitet, aber viele richtig
gute Programmierer, die haben sich auch schon, als sie ein bisschen jünger war, dafür interessiert,
muss nicht zwangsläufig erst zur Ausbildung oder zum Studium gewesen sein, also ich kenne viele,
die sind, die, also von denen ich denke, dass sie richtig, richtig Plan haben, richtig gut sind,
die hatten da vorher auch schon ein gewisses Interesse dran, mag aber wahrscheinlich daran
liegen, dass die Leute nicht einfach random sagen, ich studiere jetzt Informatik oder ich mache jetzt
eine Ausbildung in dem Bereich, sondern die sagen das, weil sie der Bereich interessiert, also kommt
ja, kommt wahrscheinlich eher eins zum anderen. Ich glaube, Quereinsteiger gibt es hier in dem Fall
gar nicht in der Umfrage. Something else gibt es. Ja, okay, was haben wir noch? Learning to Code
Developer. Okay, welche Ressourcen benutzen die Leute zum Programmieren lernen? Online Ressourcen,
Videos, Blogs, Forum. Ja, das benutze ich auch. Ich gucke Webcasts an, Konferenz-Talks,
ich lese auf Reddit, ich lese in Forum, früher zumindest jetzt weniger, Blogs lese ich in letzter
Zeit weniger. Ich habe E-Books mittlerweile, bin ich, ich habe noch hier, ich habe noch ein
ultra-fettes .net-Framework-WPF-Buch von 2008 oder so, so richtig fettes irgendwie mit 1500, das ist
richtig fett. Das ist fetter als Herr der Ringe, dieses Buch, das ist mega fett. Aber das benutze
ich heute, ich benutze heute eigentlich physische Bücher, Bücher heute tatsächlich relativ wenig.
E-Books, E-Books auf jeden Fall, also das würde ich auch sagen. Schule? Nee, war bei mir nix mit
Programmieren lernen, beziehungsweise mit überhaupt gar nix. Online-Kurse und Zertifizierung? Ja klar,
Online-Kurse benutze ich auch, logischerweise. Ich habe auch schon den ein oder anderen Kurs mal
irgendwo gekauft. Ist manchmal, manchmal ist es einfach so, dass selbst wenn du auf YouTube suchst,
du findest einfach nix, nix wirklich tiefgreifendes Gutes. YouTube ist auch schwierig, ganz ehrlich,
tiefgreifende Videos zu einem Thema gehen auf YouTube nicht so gut. Also du kannst auf Video
wunderbar hochladen, zum Beispiel Terraform-Einstiegskurs. Nehmen wir mal irgendwas, was ich letztens zum
Beispiel mir mal im Detail ein bisschen angeguckt habe. Terraform-Einstiegskurse findest du auf
YouTube jede Menge. Wenn du mal einen Kurs haben willst, der Terraform-Advanced-Topics-Covered,
auch geiler Satz, oder? Also wenn jemand was sucht, was Terraform-Advanced-Topics-Covered,
war das jetzt mehr Deutsch oder mehr Englisch, der Satz? Zumindest da ist es tatsächlich mal
ganz sinnvoll, sich auf Online-Plattformen umzugucken, so bei Udemy oder sonst wo. Und
da gibt es teilweise ganz gute Kurse, wo man auch ein bisschen mehr lernt, als auf YouTube. Ja,
habe ich auch schon benutzt. On-The-Job-Training. Okay, On-The-Job-Training heißt quasi beim
täglichen Arbeiten was lernen, selbstverständlich, das auch. Oder meinen die damit Schulungen während
dem Job? Naja, also Schulungen, die ich bisher gemacht habe auf der Arbeit, die waren alle eher
so bla bla bla, langweilig, wusste ich schon oder war mir nicht relevant. Aber natürlich,
man lernt auch vieles im täglichen Job. Also die oberen würde ich alle so unterstreichen.
College gibt es bei mir nicht. Friends of family member. Die Obenfrager lacken critical information,
würde ich sagen. Nee, gibt's nicht. Coding Camp auch nicht. Das auch nicht. Nee, also bei mir
würde ich die oberen, die oberen fünf, die treffen es eigentlich ganz gut. Weiß nicht,
wie sieht's bei euch aus, Chatgib? Ich denke mal, das ist bei den meisten so. So diese Dinger hier
werden es ganz gut treffen. Achso, ich habe mich verlesen. Kollegen, ja. Ja, da von denen auch,
das eine oder andere. Sicherlich, ja. Das habe ich damit jetzt verguckt, ja. Das sind Colleagues,
das sind kein College. Okay, welche Online-Resourcen verwenden die Leute gerne? Technical
Documentation. Da muss ich ehrlich sagen, ich verwende nur aus Versehen die offiziellen Docs,
weil die offiziellen Docs, ich weiß nicht, bei den meisten Projekten gebe ich lieber in Google ein
und wenn ich dann bei den offiziellen Docs lande und da auch drinnen steht, was ich haben will,
ist das okay. Aber ich google lieber, anstatt, dass ich zuerst in die offiziellen Docs gucke.
Weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber bei mir ist das so. Und dementsprechend habe ich,
ja genau, das ist so eine Mischung aus all dem, was ich auch habe. Also ich lande dann bei
Technischer Dokumentation vom jeweiligen Projekt. Stack Overflow, selbstverständlich. Ich glaube,
die meisten etwas schwierigeren Sachen findet man trotzdem noch, zumindest teilweise auf Stack
Overflow. Blog-Einträge findet man auch relativ oft. How-to-Videos gucke ich auch. Written Tutorials
und Blogs ist ja relativ ähnlich. Auch Video-based Online-Courses, auch Online-Books,
auch Online-Forum, auch was? Written-based Online-Kurses, was auch immer das sein soll.
Coding Sessions Live, klar, selbstverständlich. WOTS gucke ich mir auch auf YouTube an,
wo Leute irgendwas zeigen. Interactive Tutorial. Ja, da gibt es so ein paar, gibt es immer so ein
paar, so bei Sveld gibt es das auch, so eine Sandbox, wo man so ein paar Tutorials machen
kann und bei Go auch. Das ist ganz cool, mache ich aber selten. Online-Challenges,
ja klar, mache ich auch. Haben wir schon, haben wir sogar im Stream schon gemacht. Zetge-Servers
zum Beispiel. Die Search Engine und Docs sind meistens richtig kacke. Zertifizierungs-Videos
nur gucke ich mir nicht an. Selten, selten. Games that teach Programming, ne, ne, das auch nicht.
Also ich würde sagen fast alles bis auf die, bis das, außer das, außer das und außer das. Von
dem Programmieren bei mir im Studium war ich maximal enttäuscht. Programmieren gab es bei
mir zwei Module. Und man hat nur die Basics in Java gelernt, also absolute Basics, was sind
Pointer, was sind Variablen, wie macht man ein If-Statement. Du hast aber schon mal was gelernt,
du sagst nicht, dass es eine If-Schleife ist. Wenn ich einen höre mit If-Schleife,
dann kriege ich schon Anfälle. Und dann noch ein bisschen OOP mit Technologien. Was hast du denn
studiert? Also wenn es Informatik war, dann ist ein bisschen wenig Programmieren, zwei Monate und
fertig. Zwei Module und fertig. If-Schleife, then cringe. Ja, so ist es. Ist es, aber der
Vorteil davon ist, die haben meistens ein paar Beispiele dabei, die den offiziellen Docs nicht
drinstehen. Okay, also, nächstes, was haben wir denn? Online-Courses. Okay, Udemy habe ich auch
schon benutzt, ja, richtig. Udacity kenne ich nicht. Ich kenne, Audacity kenne ich,
das ist so ein Audiobearbeitungsprogramm, aber Udacity kenne ich nicht. Das habe ich schon mal
gehört, glaube ich. Pluralsight habe ich auch schon mal gehört. Also, wirklich wissentlich,
jetzt wo ich daran denke, würde ich sagen, eigentlich nur Udemy. Okay, da hätte ich eigentlich
gedacht, dass man ein bisschen mehr Programmieren hat, als nur so ein bisschen, ja, Basics to Basics.
So, Experience. Years of Coding. Also, also professionally kann ich dazu gar nichts sagen,
weil ich verdiene ja mein Geld nicht als Professional Developer. Also, wenn es danach
geht, bin ich, weiß ich nicht, ob ich überhaupt dran teilnehmen könnte, aber, also angefangen zu
programmieren habe ich damals noch mit, da war .NET 2 relativ neu, also sagen wir mal so 2004
oder sowas. Das bedeutet 2023, wenn nicht 2004, 19 Jahre Experience, also irgendwie hier sowas in
dem Dreh. More than 50 years. Wie haben sie denn das gemacht? Ich meine, die müssten ja heute
quasi mal locker 65 plus sein und die haben wahrscheinlich damals Kobol gemacht, irgendwie
in den 70ern oder so. Ja, Kobol und Fortran und irgendwelche IBM Hosts. Rex, Rex war auch so ein
Ding oder Basic, ja. Ja, gut, das ist ja so eine Verteilung, das klingt jetzt irgendwie ganz,
ganz interessant. Okay, lasst mal kurz gucken. Durchschnitt bei Countries. Okay, in Deutschland
haben die Leute im Durchschnitt 14,7 Jahre Erfahrung. In PETA von Microsoft Gold Support
hat nur 7,7 und in Australien, nicht Austria, sondern wirklich Australia, haben sie 17,5.
Hey, das sind ja die Mates aus Australien richtig weit vorne. Okay, Professional Coding. Tja Leute,
dürfte ich da überhaupt mitmachen? Ich meine, ich bin, also mein Jobtitel ist nicht Entwickler.
Also ne, dürfte ich wahrscheinlich nicht mitmachen. Ich meine, ich habe schon Sachen
professionally entwickelt für die Arbeit, was dann auch benutzt wurde, aber ich habe keinen
Titel, dass ich Developer bin. Also das gilt für mich nicht. Ach doch, anscheinend gilt das,
gilt das doch für mich. Ja, das gebe ich mal, das ist ja geil. Developer Type. Okay, die meisten
sind Fullstack, gefolgt von Backend und Frontend. Ja gut, das hätte ich mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt,
hätte ich das auch so erwartet. Und ich glaube, viele, die Fullstack sind, haben trotzdem einen
Schwerpunkt. Ja, also gut, das hätte ich auch so erwartet. Als nächstes haben wir Desktop oder
Enterprise Applications. Mobile. Engineering Manager. Wusste gar nicht, dass das auch ein
Programmierer ist oder ein Entwickler ist. Okay. Embedded Applications. Data Scientist. Guck mal,
da wäre ich, da wäre ich dabei gewesen hier. Das ist relativ langweilige Statistik. Germany
ist auf Platz 2. Ja gut, Leute, die bei der Umfrage mitgemacht haben, klar. Gefolgt von
Indien, dann UK. Okay. Die Inder, die wollen es wissen, ja. Demographics. Ich werde dieses Jahr
39. Das heißt, ich falle da rein. Ich gehöre nicht mehr zur größten Gruppe, ich gehöre jetzt schon
dahin. Ja, genau so sieht es aus, Chris. Ich glaube, die meisten von euch sind in dem Bereich. Aber
wir haben auch viele in dem Bereich. Absteigender Ast, ja. Jetzt wird es interessant. Jetzt wird
es interessanter. Technology. Most Popular Technologies. Da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt,
was da rauskommt. Das ist eigentlich immer der interessanteste Abschnitt bei diesen ganzen
Umfragen. Der Rest ist immer so bla bla bla bla bla. Also, es geht los mit Programming,
Scripting und Mark-Up-Languages. Also, was sind die beliebsten Programme? Okay,
lass mich mal ran. Auf dem ersten Platz ist wahrscheinlich Python, JavaScript und Rust.
Ihr habt recht, Leute. Ja. Python, JavaScript und Rust. Wobei es mich immer wundert, dass
JavaScript dann wirklich ganz so weit vorne ist. Ja, okay. Python, JavaScript und Rust. JavaScript,
sag ich doch. Python, ja. Ach, Rust ist nicht dabei. Moment, was ist die Umfrage? Ach hier,
Most Commonly Used Programming Language. Ach, Moment. Ja, da ist Rust natürlich nicht dabei.
Die Leute finden Rust nur geil. Aber Rust benutzen tut keiner. Also, JavaScript, Python, okay, das
wundert mich. HTML, CSS. Da kommen jetzt wieder die Ersten und sagen, aber warum ist das in der
Umfrage drin? HTML und CSS sind doch gar keine richtigen Programmiersprachen. Scheiß drauf.
Zumal sie oben ja sogar auch schreiben, Scripting, also Programming und Mark-Up-Languages. Ihr kennt
mich, ihr kennt mich. Wenn es nach mir geht, könnten sie Scripting auch einfach rauslassen
und einfach nur schreiben Programming und Mark-Up-Languages, weil Scripten ist Programmieren.
Das ist ein Subset, könnte man vielleicht schon sagen. Also, Programmieren ist alles. Aber es
gibt Leute, die finden das toll, die sagen, oh, das ist ja nur ein Skript, das ist nicht
programmiert. Mein Zeug ist, nur meins ist echte Software. Wir hatten mal einen Typ bei uns auf
der alten Arbeit, war auch ein externer Consultant, der hat auch immer so Dinge erzählt. Das war
eben ein ganz komischer Typ. Der hat auch mal gesagt, der hat auch mal gesagt, das weiß ich noch, da haben
sich die Leute damals wahnsinnig drüber aufgeregt. Also, naja, der eine, den es betroffen hat, waren
sie drüber aufgeregt. Und zwar, einer hatte was zusammengeskriptet, um was zu automatisieren.
Und da meinte dann der externe Fivehead-Consultant, er hat nicht Unrecht, muss ich gleich dazu sagen,
meinte, ja, in welchem Git-Repo finde ich denn das? Und da meinte der Entwickler, ach nee, das habe
ich nirgendswo eingecheckt, das liegt bei mir. Und da meinte der Typ halt eiskalt, was nicht
eingecheckt ist, ist keine Software. Dann behalte dein Kram. Dann behalte dein Kram, was nicht
eingecheckt ist, ist keine Software. Also, das war schon echt, also, das ist halt das Problem. Du
kannst die Sachen sagen, mit der gleichen Message, aber ohne, dass die Leute abgefuckt sind. Und
gerade als externer Consultant-Berater, wo man irgendwie ein bisschen darauf angewiesen ist,
dass die Leute einem, sagen wir mal, eine gute Note geben, ist es vielleicht blöd, ja. Hätte der
gesagt, ach, schick mal rüber, oder dann checkst du doch am besten mal ein, dann kann ich Änderungen
dran machen, vollkommen okay. Aber sowas will ich nicht gutheißen, weil ich finde zwar die
prinzipielle Aussage dahinter nicht verkehrt, ja, aber die Art und Weise, wie er es gesagt hat,
ist für den Arsch. Deswegen finde ich das nicht gut. Und er hat es verdient, dass seine Sache nicht
verlängert wurde, weil er hat oftmals solche blöden Sprüche gemacht. Auch wenn er von der
eigentlichen Sache dahinter gar keine, ja, gar nicht so Unrecht hat, finde ich, sollte man schon
ein bisschen darauf achten, wie man die Sachen sagt, dass man nicht unnötig die Leute abfuckt.
Weil ganz ehrlich, gutes Betriebsklima ist mindestens genauso wichtig, wie dass man Leute hat,
die sich mit Technik auskennen. So, oder was ist mit Musik los? MonkaS? Okay, jetzt geht's los. Was
ist deine Meinung zu C++? Der Chat will mich wieder gebaten, glaube ich. Was kommt eigentlich
als nächstes für den C++-Standard? Was ist eigentlich der nächste C++-Standard, der kommt?
Weil 2023 hatten wir jetzt, ja? Der ist noch gar nicht verabschiedet. Es ist Mitte 2023. Was kommt
denn danach dann? In welchem Intervall machen die das immer? Drei Jahre. Also gibt es dann C++26
irgendwann? Hier kommt C++26. Das ist aber nicht viel, was die sich schon ausgedacht haben. Okay,
also was haben wir denn hier sonst noch für Programmiersprachen? JavaScript, HTML, CSS,
Python, SQL, TypeScript, Bash, ja, Shell-Geschichten, Java, C Sharp. Also wie gesagt,
es geht nicht darum, was die Leute gut finden in dem jetzt, in dem Fall, sondern was verbreitet
ist. Und ja, JavaScript war mir klar, dass JavaScript verbreitet als Fuck ist. Ich meine,
JavaScript ist nicht nur Frontend und es gibt sehr viele Anwendungen, die haben heute einfach
nur noch ein Webfrontend. Aber mittlerweile ist JavaScript ja auch für die eigentliche
Applikationsanwendung backend-seitig beliebt. Sei es jetzt mit Node.js oder wenn man Sachen direkt
mit irgendwelchen Cloud-Datenbanken und sowas integriert, ist alles JavaScript. Ja, das wundert
mich nicht. TypeScript wundert mich auch nicht. HTML, CSS wundert mich logischerweise auch nicht
in Kombination. Python wundert mich auch nicht, war auch schon immer relativ hoch. SQL, gut,
Evergreen, kommst du nicht drumherum. Ich habe nicht viel Plan von SQL, muss ich sagen, aber
dass das immer noch und weiterhin wird es das auch sein, relevant, das ist klar. Bash finde
ich ist auch eine nicht unwichtige Geschichte, gerade für irgendwelche Buildscripts, Automatisierung
oder sowas. Vieles macht man einfach mal ganz schnell mit ein paar Zeilen im Shell-Skript,
schneller, einfacher und problemloser als mit anderen Sachen. So, dann kommt Java, gut,
wundert mich auch überhaupt nicht. Gerade im Enterprise-Umfeld ist Java einfach sehr beliebt.
Also wenn ihr bei irgendeiner Bank arbeitet, Versicherung arbeitet oder irgendwo ein bisschen
ein Hauch der Business-Enterprise-Welt mitschwingt, da könnt ihr dir vor ausgehen, die Hälfte von
denen ist in Java. C-Sharp, ja, wundert mich auch nicht, finde ich gut, dass das mittlerweile so
weit vorne mit dabei ist. Hauptsächlich nicht ganz so stark verbreitet im Business-Enterprise-Umfeld
wie Java, aber auch, allerdings hat C-Sharp natürlich noch einen großen Platz, was Windows-Entwicklung
und sowas angeht. Oder halt auch vieles, die viele Unternehmen, die Windows-Anwendungen gemacht haben
und jetzt sich ein bisschen breiter aufgestellt haben, die haben halt Ahnung und Expertise mit
C-Sharp, das passt. Peepo, please, dance. Musik, ja. Egal. Next. Was haben wir denn sonst noch? Go!
Go ist so weit unten, aber zum Glück ist C++ auch nicht weit oben. Na gut, aber direkt nach C-Sharp,
C, P, PAP, Rust, Ruby, Lua, Dart. Ja gut, Dart ist aus dem einzigen Grund überhaupt in dieser Liste
drin, weil die Leute Flutter verwenden. Dart für sich genommen hat keine Relevanz bei
Programmiersprachen. VisualBasic.net. Leute, ist jemand von euch noch in der blöden Situation
VisualBasic.net machen zu müssen? Das liegt nicht daran. Das liegt nicht daran. Es hat aber, es hat
einen ähnlichen Grund. Es hat einen ähnlichen Grund, warum ich das mache. Nicht, nicht, weil ich mich
vercopypastet habe. Also nicht, nicht, weil ich Commandos copypastet habe. Das war, du hast nicht
schlecht geraten. Der eigentliche Grund ist recht ähnlich. Zogsam, du musst vor VisualBasic.net
machen. Alter. Wie hätte man da noch vor ein paar Jahren gesagt, Bruder muss los. Das ist ja auch
nicht mehr modern, das sagt man ja auch nicht. Groovy. Ja gut. Ich hab mal eine Sache in der
Gru- Also eine Anwendung klingt jetzt wahnsinnig übertrieben. Ich hab mal für unser altes Confluence
Wiki was automatisiert mit Groovy. Man braucht irgendwas auf Java-Basis, weil Confluence selbst
auf Java-Basis läuft. Das war ganz okay eigentlich. Ich meine keine Programmiersprache, wo ich mich
jetzt drum reißen würde, aber es war okay. Wird das eigentlich noch aktiv weiterentwickelt? Ja,
anscheinend. Delphi Scala Perl. Wisst ihr eigentlich, dass- Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob es Turbo Pascal oder Delphi war. Ich sag's jetzt einfach mal trotzdem. Wisst ihr eigentlich,
dass der C-Sharp Erfinder und TypeScript Erfinder auch Delphi mit erfunden hat,
oder es könnte auch Turbo Pascal gewesen sein. Ich weiß es gerade aus dem Kopf nicht. Also der
gleiche Typ ist hier gleich mit drei Sprachen vertreten. TypeScript, C-Sharp und tja. Ich sag
jetzt einfach mal Delphi, auch wenn ich mir da nicht ganz sicher bin. Anders Heilsberg,
wobei man den sicherlich anders ausspricht. Richtiger Fivehead-Dude. Apex. Flow. Weiß
nicht mehr, was das sein soll. Raku. Crystal. Okay, das hier unten ist ja nur wirklich jetzt
die- Kobol. Fortran auch grad die Armen, Leute. Okaml. Ist das nicht auch so eine Sprache mit 30
Milliarden Klammern und Sonderzeichen drinne? Was Funktionales. Der erste Rust-Compiler war
in Okaml programmiert, glaube ich. Ich weiß nicht, wie man das ausspricht. Okaml? Okaml? So,
wie geht's? Databases. Postgres. Vollkommen zurecht, Leute. Postgres ist- Also, ich kann
euch die Theorie dahinter nicht erklären. Ja, also, was Datenbanktheorie angeht, fragt mich
nicht. Aber ich kann es euch aus Entwicklersicht sagen. Postgres ist einfach das Beste, was es
gibt von den Features her. Dass du- Allein schon, dass du damit so Sachen machen kannst, wie- Also
nicht nur, dass du Volltextsuche machen kannst, was ja mittlerweile sogar SQLite ein bisschen kann.
Du kannst Volltextsuche machen. Du kannst allerdings Autocomplete-Sachen machen,
weil die so eine Tree-Cram-Search haben, dass du quasi auch Teilstrings suchen kannst. Die
haben mittlerweile eine Timeseries-Datenbank drinne. Postgres ist einfach das Beste,
was es gibt. Feature-wise. Das bewundert mich, dass das nicht die letzten Jahre schon auf Platz
1 gewesen ist. Beste. Ja, gut, danach MySQL- SQLite. Auch vollkommen zurecht. Klar kann man
jetzt sagen, okay, warum steht da Postgres und SQLite irgendwie in der gleichen Tabelle? Ja,
gut, wie sollen sie das- Oder ich meine, da steht auch Redis drinne. Das sind drei
komplett unterschiedliche Parchur. Das ist eher so eine, nenn ich mal so eine In-Memory-Cache-Geschichte.
Das ist eine Neu-SQL-Datenbank. Also eine klassische Relational-Datenbank. Und das ist
so eher was für Embedded-Geschichten. Also hast drei komplett unterschiedliche Parchur,
aber was sollen sie machen? Also Postgres vollkommen zurecht. SQLite auch vollkommen
zurecht. Ich würde fast behaupten, dass SQLite die verbreitetste Datenbank der Welt ist. Jede
Android-Anwendung hat eine SQLite-Datenbank. Ich vermute auch mal, jede iOS-Anwendung hat
eine SQLite-Datenbank. Sehr viele Desktop-Anwendungen haben eine SQLite-Datenbank
drinne. Und auch ganz viele kleineren Services, die man bei sich laufen lassen kann, haben SQLite.
Habe ich NoSQL gesagt? Ich meine SQLite. Haben eine SQLite-Datenbank drinne. Also haben wir auch
hier im Stream schon oft verwendet. Beste. Ja, warum da so ein Shit wie Microsoft SQL Server
drin ist, weiß ich auch nicht. Liegt wahrscheinlich einfach daran, weil viele Leute irgendwie hängen
geblieben sind auf Windows immer noch seit Jahren. MariaDB. Leute, was ist denn der Unterschied
zwischen MySQL und MariaDB? Ich dachte eigentlich, dass MySQL und MariaDB das gleiche sind und dass
beide sogar mittlerweile von Oracle gekauft, also dass MySQL von Oracle gekauft wurde. Oracle. Ja
gut, Oracle ist so weit unten einfach, weil es schweineteuer ist. DynamoDB ist das von Azure?
Ne, bring ich das jetzt durcheinander? Von Google? Von Azure? Von AWS? Ne. Wer ist DynamoDB nochmal?
AWS, gell? AWS. Bigtable ist das NoSQL von Google? Ich habe gerade vergessen, wie hieß
denn der Krempel von Microsoft? CloudSQ? Ne. Wie heißt nochmal von Azure, den ihr hosted,
managed, ähm, NoSQL, Key-Value, Dings, Gedöns. Dachte ich Access, Blödsinn. Azure. CosmosDB,
das meine ich. Ja, CosmosDB. Steht hier gar nicht drinnen. Doch, da. Das meine ich. Firebase? Okay,
Cloud Firestorm, BigQuery. Das ist auch Google. Microsoft Access. Also, die lacken wirklich alle
Critical Information, wenn das der Fall ist. Superbase. Das hätte ich gar nicht gedacht,
dass es da überhaupt darauf auftaucht. Das ist ja relativ neu und hätte gar nicht gedacht,
dass es nennenswerte Verbreitungen hat. Okay, InfluxDB für Timeseries-Datenbanken. CassandraDB
für Cloud-Native-World-Distributed-Datenbank-Gedöns. DB2, MonkaS, Alter. Yep, CockroachDB. DackDB,
habe ich noch nie was von gehört. Clickhouse kenne ich auch nicht. Klingt wie irgendeine
Analytik-Plattform. Okay, Cloud-Plattforms. Da bin ich mal gespannt. AWS? Tatsächlich?
Tatsächlich? Okay. Achso, meist benutzt. Nicht meist gemocht. Meist benutzt. Ja,
okay. Das kann ich mir vorstellen. Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen. AWS ist extrem beliebt.
Gefolgt von den anderen. Ja, gut. Firebase. Firebase müsste man wahrscheinlich so ein
bisschen noch bei Google mit draufrechnen, weil ich glaube, das basiert ja komplett auf
Google Cloud-Technologie, Firebase. So, Cloudflare. Okay, DigitalOcean, Heroku. Heroku ist auch sehr
abgefallen. Heroku war eines der allerersten, nennen wir es mal Clouds in dem Sinn, wobei es
damals noch nicht eine richtige Cloud war, wie man sich das heute vorstellt, sondern eher eine
Möglichkeit, seine Anwendung recht easy zu hosten, was Entwickler halt sehr gemocht haben damals,
dass du quasi einfach nur ein Git-Repo gebraucht hast, ein Remote-Git-Repo, du hast den richtigen
Branch gepusht, das hat deployt und die Anwendung war live. Ich glaube, Heroku hat damals angefangen
mit Hosting für Ruby on Rails und war eine Zeit lang extrem beliebt, weit bevor es diesen
ganzen anderen Crampel gegeben hat. Hetzner ist auch drin, guck mal. Netlify. Netlify ist auch die
letzten paar Jahre, das ist auch sehr schnelllebig, die letzten paar Jahre ein bisschen abgefallen.
Netlify war mal eine Weile die Go-To-Plattform, also die Plattform schlechthin für so Caching
und Frontend-Hosten für, wie nennt man das so cool heutzutage in der Frontend-Entwicklung,
wie nennt man das nochmal Leute in der Frontend-Entwicklung, dass man die Sachen
möglichst nah, Edge-Computing meine ich, jetzt ist mir das wieder eingefallen, Edge-Computing.
Aber in den letzten Jahren, in den letzten zwei Jahren oder so, ist Vercell total steil gegangen.
Ich glaube sogar, dass Vercell die Svelte-Entwicklung irgendwie sponsort, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe.
Rand-Komputierung. Bist du auch ein Internet-Stehsegler etwa? Oder Vercell sponsort Next?
Hatte Vercell nicht auch irgendwas mit Svelte zu tun? Mit Svelte-Kit zu tun?
Ich glaube, der Svelte-Entwickler arbeitet bei Vercell, oder? Kann das sein?
Vielleicht bringe ich das auch durcheinander jetzt.
Na doch, anscheinend hatten die mal ein bisschen was miteinander zu tun.
Okay, Next.
Web-Frameworks and Technologies. Okay, da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt.
Aber so ist das halt. Wenn du eine Anwendung hast, die vor 15 Jahren erstellt wurde,
dann enthält die halt jQuery und du musst heute immer noch jQuery verwenden,
wenn sie nicht mal grundlegend geändert wurde. So ist das halt.
Node.js ist klar, React ist auch klar. Ganz ehrlich, das verwundert mich nicht.
Das ist einfach mit am verbreitetsten überhaupt.
Express wundert mich jetzt auch nicht. Angular, ja gut, weil böseres Enterprise-Umfeld.
Anderweitig kann ich mir das nicht erklären. Next, weil React.
ASP.NET Core vollkommen verdient. Man muss halt sagen,
Web-Framework-Technologies, das ist hier so ein bisschen sehr gemischt.
Frontend-Framework, Backend-Geschichten, vollkommen verdient.
Wenn ihr mich fragt, ist ASP.NET Core mit das angenehmste Framework für Backend-seitig,
wo man überhaupt mit arbeiten kann.
Du findest Go besser als Node.js. Ja gut, kann ja jeder verwenden, was er will.
Aber du hast einen unbestreitbaren Vorteil, was Node.js angeht.
Und das ist, dass es für jeden Furz, was du frontend-mäßig machen willst, Packages gibt.
Stell dir mal vor, du brauchst einen Syntax-Highlighter für HTML.
Code-Blocks in HTML willst du Syntax-Highlighten.
Find mal was in Go, find mal was in JavaScript.
Klar, was da einfacher ist.
Also wer sich jetzt vielleicht fragt, warum ich ASP.NET Core so abfeier und ASP.NET nicht mag,
das liegt daran, weil die Benahmung von Microsoft halt mal wieder extrem beschissen ist.
ASP.NET Core hat eigentlich gar nichts mit ASP.NET zu tun.
ASP.NET Core ist eine komplette Neuentwicklung, die neu entwickelt wurde zusammen mit .NET Core.
.NET Core ist die Weiterentwicklung, ist die geistige Fortführung vom .NET Framework,
hat aber von der Codebase her nichts mit dem .NET Framework zu tun.
Die haben es .NET Core genannt und ASP.NET Core, um es von dem .NET Framework und ASP.NET Core klar abzugrenzen.
Und irgendwann kam Microsoft dann auf die glorreiche Idee, nämlich nach .NET Core 3 kam Microsoft auf die Idee,
das ganze nur noch .NET zu nennen.
Und jetzt passt mal auf, und jetzt wird es extrem abgedreht.
Die letzte Version von .NET Framework ist 4.8.
Es gab allerdings dann ein .NET 5.
Und wer jetzt etwa denkt, dass .NET 5 eine Weiterentwicklung von .NET Framework 4.8 ist, der liegt falsch.
.NET 5 ist die Weiterentwicklung von .NET Core 3 und hat mit .NET Framework nichts zu tun.
Also Microsoft und Benahmung, das ist einfach nur für den Arsch.
Das plickt wirklich niemand.
Also alles was .NET Framework ist, suckt.
Und alles was ASP.NET ist, suckt.
Was .NET ist oder .NET Core, vielleicht manchmal noch genannt wird, oder ASP.NET Core, das ist Porc, das ist gut.
Sehr gut überlegt, ja, korrekt. Das ist Microsoft-Logik.
Ja, WordPress, das haben sich die richtigen ja gefunden, WordPress und ASP.NET zusammen.
FastAPI und Svelte.
Ich finde es sehr interessant, dass Svelte hier drauf sogar schon auftaucht.
Weil Svelte ist nicht wirklich super verbreitet in der Enterprise-Welt, dachte ich bisher.
Aber finde ich gut. Nimmt auch immer weiter zu.
Ruby on Rails ist auch noch da, NestJS, Blazer.
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass irgendjemand ernsthaft Blazer-Anwendungen macht.
Deno, Phönix, Trupal.
Ich weiß nicht mal was das sein soll.
SolidJS, ist SolidJS nicht irgendwie in den React-Plots ein bisschen schneller?
Im Professional Tab, ok, guck mal Svelte.
Ne, im Professional Tab ist es auch ganz gut drin.
Nice.
Ne, es ist witzigerweise alles ungefähr so gleich auf.
Also Laravel finde ich nice für PHP, Symfony habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Ok, Other Frameworks and Libraries.
Ja, vollkommen zurecht.
Microsoft hat da wirklich eine super Plattform.
Kann ich nicht anders sagen, ich mag nicht alles was Microsoft macht, ja.
Aber die haben wirklich eine gute Plattform.
Glücklicherweise haben sie das hier getrennt, weil .NET Framework und .NET ja nichts miteinander zu tun hat.
Microsoft-Benahmung.
Ok, das ist aber eine wilde Mischung.
Das ist ja eine sehr wilde Mischung hier, guck mal.
Runtime, Schrägliche Framework, NumPy, Pandas, RapidMQ, TensorFlow, Flutter.
Da ist ja alles.
Ok, das ist einfach nur random.
OpenGL, Qt, CUDA, OpenCV, React Native.
What the fuck.
Ich habe keine Ahnung was das für eine Liste sein soll.
Das ist einfach einmal querbeet.
Das ist so wie wenn irgendwie einer in ein Wiki gegangen ist, bei irgendeinem IT-Unternehmen und gesucht hat und dann irgendwie Top 50 Treffer oder so.
Maury ist da ernsthaft drinne?
Maury ist der Shitschläger, also wirklich der mieseste Müll überhaupt.
Ok, nice.
Gut, dass das so weit unten ist.
Reste-Rampe Maury, ja.
Gibt es Ionic noch?
Ah ja, da, tatsächlich.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es wirklich ernsthaft...
Leute, wenn ich euch jetzt sage, dass irgendein Low-IQ, Three-Head-Personalabteilungs-Mensch eine Stellenanzeige schreiben muss und keine Ahnung davon hat.
Und wenn der einfach hier hingeht und das rein copy-pastet als Anforderung.
Haltet ihr das für unrealistisch?
Oder denkt ihr, das könnte durchaus passieren?
So nach dem Motto, wir suchen einen Software-Entwickler.
Was soll er können?
Komm einfach das da und gut ist.
Dafür ohne scheiß Specs, dafür würde ich mich auch bewerben.
Einfach nur um mal zu sehen, was wollt ihr eigentlich?
Also sprich, was muss das für ein Laden sein, die das alles zusammen benutzen?
Uno-Plattform, das ist UI-Entwicklung.
Cross-Plattform-UI.
Ja, ich glaube auch, dass es zumindest die Sharp-Bindings oder .NET-Bindings gibt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das was reines .NET-mäßig ist.
Capacitor ist doch Ionic, oder?
MFC, Alter, was die Leute da noch haben.
Hadoop, ja, vor 15 Jahren mal mega gehypt.
So Cloud-Computing.
Und dann haben die Leute gesagt, ja, wie Map-Reduce, Hadoop.
Und dann war das Buzzword-Bingo komplett.
Aber mittlerweile juckt das ja keinem mehr.
Okay, dann haben wir noch Top-Used-Tools.
Docker, ja gut, wundert mich nicht.
Docker ist überall mittlerweile.
Und wenn nicht in der Form von Docker, dann in der Form von irgendwie anderem Kontainerisierungscampel.
Aber du brauchst trotzdem dann an manchen Stellen Docker.
Zum Beispiel auf der Arbeit.
Jetzt halt euch mal fest, ich erzähl euch mal was Lustiges.
Bürokratischer Aufwand, ja.
Also, irgendjemand dort, weil wir sind eine Versicherung.
Irgendjemand hat entschieden, wir dürfen nicht von jedem Rechner ins Internet.
Und unsere Kubernetes-Cluster und Entwicklerrechner und sowas, die dürfen schon mal gar nicht ins Internet.
Das heißt, man kann nicht einfach zu GitHub, zu GitHub-Registry, zu Docker-Registry gehen
und seine Images pullen vom Kubernetes-Cluster aus.
Nein, wir haben eine interne Registry dafür.
So weit, so gut, da sag ich nichts dagegen.
Das ist ja vollkommen, ja, fast schon normal.
So.
Aber jetzt kommt der Hit.
Normalerweise kann diese interne Registry, die wir da benutzen, sich sünken.
Beispielsweise mit Docker-Hub-Images und sowas.
Das ist dann quasi so eine Art Proxy dazwischen.
Und das ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Aber.
Und jetzt kommt's.
Unsere interne Registry ist irgendwie zu alt.
Die kann nicht die neuesten Container-Formate.
Und wenn wir Dienstleister haben oder Images brauchen aus neueren Registries,
dann wird aktuell folgender Workflow angewandt.
Irgendjemand schreibt einen...
Irgendjemand schreibt jemand...
Nein, ich muss den Satz anders sagen.
Irgendjemand, der die Images braucht, schreibt jemand an, der Rechte hat,
um in das interne Repo zu pushen.
Der macht dann einen Docker-Pull auf das offizielle Repo von der Kiste,
die ins Internet darf.
Und dann pusht er das in die interne Registry.
Und jetzt kommt der Hit.
Irgendjemand hat sich überlegt, es ist eine gute Idee,
dass man nur neue Images und Tags pushen kann und keine alten löschen.
Und wir haben einen Dienstleister, der ist äußerst pp-ger.
Naja, das ist nichts super Kritisches, was ich dir erzähle.
Und der ist super pp-ger, der Dienstleister.
Und zwar, der liefert Docker-Images oder Container-Images
und benutzt Tags mehrfach.
Also es gibt dann sowas wie Docker-Image bla blub
mit dem Tag neues Feature.
Das Problem ist, dass dieser Tag neues Feature immer wieder neu vergeben wird.
Und du hast dann mehrere Images, die den gleichen Tag haben.
Und irgendjemand bei uns hat sich jetzt überlegt,
es ist eine gute Idee, dass man bestehende Tags nicht löschen kann.
Und wisst ihr, was ich jetzt immer machen muss,
wenn der Dienstleister ein neues Image pusht?
Ich muss immer in Teams jemand anschreiben,
der die Rechte hat für dieses Repo,
dann ein Ticket aufmachen, bitte diesen Tag löschen,
dann den danach nochmal anschreiben,
so nach dem Motto, es ist eilig, mach doch mal please.
Und dann kann ich es wieder pushen.
Das ist wirklich Arbeits-, wie soll man sagen,
Arbeitsvermeidung, nee, das ist das falsche Wort.
Arbeits-, Arbeits-, ja, ja, Vermeidung, nee,
was ist das richtige Wort für, also so,
so Deluxe, ja, Arbeits-, Aufblähung Deluxe, ja.
Arbeitszeitvernichtung Deluxe, ja,
das trifft, das trifft ganz gut, ja.
Ja, das ist, das ist echt geil.
Und dann, und letztens kam noch jemand und meinte,
Max, eigentlich hatte mal jemand entschieden,
wir sollen hauptsächlich Podman benutzen und nicht Docker.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, weißt du was,
bis mich irgendjemand mal anscheißt dafür,
dass ich Docker benutze, benutze ich weiter Docker.
Soweit ich es ja gar nicht benutze, um Container laufen zu lassen,
sondern um Images zu pushen.
Aber vollkommen verständlich, vollkommen verständlich,
Docker ist vorne mit dabei,
weil Container sind immer noch, oder immer, was ist immer noch,
sind, also allgegenwärtig.
Wundert mich, NPM wundert mich auch nicht.
Ich meine, Javascript ist die weitverspreiteste Sprache,
NPM als Packagemanager und nicht nur als Packagemanager,
sondern NPM ist ja irgendwie gefühlt Tool für alles, ja.
Scriptrunner, Tool installieren, Libraries installieren,
NPM macht alles.
Oder man benutzt PNPM, wenn man cool sein will.
Pip, wundert mich auch nicht, Python Packagemanager,
und Python ist verbreitet.
Homebrew, alle macOS-User.
Yarn, Leute, die was Besonderes sein wollen,
keinen Bock auf NPM oder PNPM haben.
Webpack, leider ja, noch verbreitet.
Make, ja, leider ist so.
Kubernetes, klar, wundert mich nicht, logischerweise.
Nougat, beste, nee, ehrlich gesagt ist Nougat nicht beste.
Ich bin ja ganz ehrlich, so ein paar Sachen sind an dort nett
und sie schaben auch schon ziemlich oldschool.
Ja, dass es an manchen Stellen noch XML-Config-Files gibt,
zum Beispiel.
Und Nougat ist jetzt auch nicht der geilste Packagemanager.
Maven für unsere Java-Leute,
Vite, Vite für alle Frontend-Leute, ja.
Visual Studio Solution, hä?
Visual Studio Solution?
Was soll denn das sein?
Das CS-Brotsch-Format da,
CS-Project-Format, oder hä?
Terraform, wenn man das Bild...
Ja, okay, skippen wir mal schnell.
Integrated Development Environment.
Okay.
Visual Studio Code, wundert mich auch überhaupt nicht.
Visual Studio, ja gut, sind einige drauf hängen geblieben,
Windows-Shit, okay.
Aber Visual Studio Code, das wundert mich beim besten Willen nicht,
benutze ich auch sehr häufig.
Für alles Mögliche, klar, hauptsächlich für JavaScript-Kram,
aber man kann darin auch wirklich gut,
wenn man keinen Bock auf die JetBrains-Sachen hat,
kann man darauf auch wirklich gut Python machen,
also nicht nur JavaScript, oder auch Go,
wobei es da manchmal Probleme gibt,
wenn man Interop-Sachen machen will,
aber ich glaube, das ist gefixt.
Oder auch für solche Sachen wie Plattform-IO,
wenn man Microcontroller und C++ machen will,
ist schon ganz gut, ja.
Also verdient, verdient.
Visual Studio, ja, bin ich weg davon,
ich benutze Rider für C-Sharp überall.
Windows, Linux, na gut, Mac mache ich nix,
aber Windows, Linux benutze ich, benutze ich Rider.
Notepad++, die Beliebtheit habe ich noch nie verstanden,
wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Vim, ja.
Android Studio, Logo, PyCharm, ja, gute Sache.
Sublime Text, dass das noch so viele benutzen,
wundert mich tatsächlich.
Neo Eclipse, MonkaS, Alter, Eclipse.
Okay, jetzt kommt das ganze JetBrains-Gedöns,
das können wir skippen.
Und dass das hier eigens aufgeführt ist, na gut.
NetBeans, Qt Creator.
Fleet, tatsächlich.
Manche Leute benutzen schon Fleet.
Okay, Ticket-Systeme und Wikis und sowas.
Jira oder Jaira, wie es manche Leute,
die besonders trendig sein wollen, aussprechen.
Jaira, oder was ich mal von einem gehört habe,
der hat gesagt, Jaira, hat er gesagt.
Jaira.
Der hat aber auch alles geil ausgesprochen, Jaira.
Ich glaube, offiziell ist es Jira,
oder es könnte auch Jira sein,
weil ich habe mal gelesen,
es kommt von irgendwas Japanischem.
Okay, Confluence, das wundert mich nicht,
dass diese Atlassian-Dinger hier verbreitet sind.
Es gibt kaum ein Business,
was nicht in irgendeiner Art und Weise
mal irgendwo in Jira und Confluence rumstehen hat.
Zumal es auch mittlerweile ja eher davon abgehalten wird,
selbst zu hosten,
sondern die Cloud-Version zu benutzen.
Markdown-Files benutzt auch jeder.
Trello, Kackle-Web braucht sowas.
GitHub-Discussions, klar.
Azure DevOps kenne ich noch aus einer Azure-Schulung,
die ich mal mitmachen musste.
Benutzt habe ich nie,
da hatte ich auch keinen Bock drauf.
Wikis, ja klar.
Asana sagt mir nichts.
Kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor vom Namen, aber.
Redmine, alter, wer Redmine muss ernsthaben.
Also, mein Beileid, wer noch Redmine benutzen muss.
Stackoverflow for Teams,
mir war nicht bekannt, dass es sowas überhaupt gibt.
Synchronous-Tools.
Microsoft Teams, ja, wundert mich nicht.
Die ganzen Instant-Messaging-Tools sind irgendwie kacke,
außer Discord.
Aber von allen, denen die kacke sind,
finde ich Microsoft Teams noch am wenigsten kacke.
Das ist auch zu Recht davon.
Ja, Slack, weil es als erstes da war,
bleibt es.
Zoom, ganz ehrlich,
Zoom ist nur wegen Corona ganz vorne mit dabei.
Weiß nicht, ob das noch neue User bekommt,
aber es ist halt einfach verbreitet, as fuck.
Discord.
Wundert mich persönlich,
dass viele Leute da Discord benutzen.
Weil ja, glaube ich,
da die Datenschutzlage noch unklarer ist
als bei Teams und sowas.
Aber, ja, interessant.
Rein von der Software her
würde ich Discord jederzeit
diesen ganzen anderen Dingen hervorziehen.
Ja, geil.
Ich will auch schon immer schreiben über WhatsApp,
so nach dem Motto,
guck mal, please den Pull-Request an.
Skype.
Gut, sind auch manche Leute,
sind auf Skype for Business hängen geblieben und sowas.
Okay.
IRC.
Ja, das sind die richtigen Hackermans, Leute.
Die IRC-User,
das sind wahrscheinlich hier die,
die mit dem Professional-Crime-Set-Mindset
oder so was,
die schaffen das weg,
was fünf andere Leute,
also die schaffen an einem Tag das,
was andere Leute in der Woche schaffen,
Teams-Benutzer.
Die richtig Hardcore-Hackermans,
die benutzen immer noch IRC.
Was ist IRC mit AV1-Mod?
AV1 ist ein Videocodec.
Und IRC ist Text.
Operating System.
Personal Use.
Windows.
Professional Use.
Mein Beileid.
Oh shit, ich muss es ja selbst Professional-Usen.
Aber ich hab meine Linux-VM,
wo ich einfach per Fullscreen-Terminal eingeloggt bin.
Ist mir egal, was da unten drunter ist.
Das war auch mal mehr.
Ja, glücklicherweise,
weil Windows einfach für Professional-Usage kacke ist.
Wenn man Sachen programmieren will
oder administrieren will.
Da ist...
Sackt Windows einfach.
Windows hat seine Stärken.
Ich hab ja da sogar ein Video drüber gemacht.
Aber für so was
sackt Windows einfach nur ganz hart.
Jubantu ist auch mal wieder am Start.
Das ist ein bisschen wie Windows.
Jubantu.
Android.
Windows Subsystem.
Okay.
Arch.
Endlich.
Das Beste.
Da ist es.
Pog.
Yep.
Yep, Arch.
Professional Use.
Das sind die richtigen RKMans.
Leute, ich sag euch in Kombination.
Arch plus IRC.
Das sind...
Die sind ganz oben mit dabei.
AI Search Tools.
Ja, juckt mich jetzt nicht weiter.
AI Developer Tools.
Copilot.
Ja.
Klar.
Was sonst?
Das finde ich auch immer sehr interessant.
Was die Leute quasi haben wollen
versus was die Leute cool finden.
Javascript.
Python TypeScript C Sharp Rust.
Ja.
Go ist auch...
Ja, ja.
Bash.
Okay.
Wollen...
Admired.
60%.
Ja, so gehört es.
Das Bash Script Beste hier.
Guck mal.
Aber man muss sagen.
C Sharp ist auch sehr gut dabei.
Mit 62%.
Rust ist natürlich immer wieder...
Die Rust Task Force war aktiv.
84%.
Databases.
Postgres.
Die hatten wir ja schon.
Cloud Plattform.
Ja, das müssen wir uns jetzt nicht mehr angucken.
Aber die hatten doch irgendwo
ziemlich gute...
Ah, das ist jetzt auch nicht mehr.
Das ist ja eigentlich nur alles in anderer Weise dargestellt.
Die hatten doch eine ziemlich gute...
Top Paying Technologies.
Okay, das ist tatsächlich interessant.
SIG.
Es gibt Leute, die SIG suchen.
Wirklich?
Okay.
Erlang.
Alles klar.
F Sharp.
Ruby.
Guck mal.
C Sharp Entwickler will keiner.
Ja gut.
Ruby Entwickler werden gut bezahlt.
Das liegt daran.
Alle sind mittlerweile von Ruby on Rails weg.
Alle, die noch eine Legacy Ruby on Rails Anwendung betreuen müssen,
die brauchen einen Ruby Entwickler.
Und es gibt kaum noch welche.
Ja, Go ist auch...
Perl.
Ja.
Genau der gleiche Grund.
Was ist SIG?
Eine Programmiersprache.
Cobol.
Naja.
Ja, das finde ich jetzt tatsächlich auch nicht so wahnsinnig spannend mehr.
Aber die hatten irgendwo eine gute Übersicht.
Dieses Admired Desired.
Da gab es eine gute Übersicht.
Das ist jetzt aber...
Wo haben sie denn das?
Das haben...
Ja.
Wie die arbeiten, ist mir auch relativ egal.
Sennory bei Developer Time.
Das können wir uns alles nochmal im Detail angucken demnächst.
Was ich mich jetzt noch interessieren will.
Also Leute, mein Plan ist,
ich will jetzt noch irgendwie eineinhalb Stunden parken und Battlefield spielen gleich.
Die hatten doch irgendwo...
Ich hab da vorhin kurz reingeguckt und das sah anders aus.
Haben die die Graphen ausgetauscht oder so?
Das sah vorhin noch anders aus.
Ist mein Darkreader an und macht komisches Zeug?
Die haben die Graphen ausgetauscht.
Das sah vorhin noch anders aus.
Okay.
Nee, das sah anders aus.
Ich...
Das waren vorhin solche...
Solche Graphs waren das vorhin.
Und man konnte umschalten zwischen...
Ed Meier und Desired.
Kann das sein?
Moment mal, Moment mal.
War ich vorhin vielleicht zufällig in 2022?
Oh.
Ich glaube ich war vorher...
In 2022.
Okay.
Äh, ja.
Ähm, das würde es tatsächlich erklären.
Okay.
Ja, alles, alles klar.
Na das, das erklärt es natürlich.
Okay, dass React vorne ist, wundert mich tatsächlich überhaupt gar nicht.
Was Webframeworks angeht.
React ist...
35% wollen es haben und 63% finden es geil.
Ich finde, ich finde...
Was ich wirklich spannend finde ist...
Wo ist denn Svelte?
Weil wenn es nach da geht...
Ja, weil Svelte ist auch...
Ja, weil Svelte ist auch mit das beliebteste Webframework.
Moment!
Ja, Angular ist dahinten.
Also AST hier, 74%, das ist mit das beliebteste.
Plus Phoenix kommt noch mehr.
Ja, bei Programmiersprachen ist es Rust.
Was total hier Rust 84% entmeidet.
Ich finde, ich finde das aber echt gut.
Weil, also was man hier sieht...
Das wundert mich nicht mit React, dass React da ganz vorne mit dabei ist.
Node, Next, Vue, ja, Vue hat auf jeden Fall stark eingebüßt die letzten Jahre über.
Das war mal mit das beliebteste Web-Technologie und ist jetzt runter auf 57%, wirklich ganz
stark eingebüßt.
Wann guckst du mal in ein Projekt den Rust rein?
Wir haben ganz kurz beim Stream schon ein paar Sachen gemacht, aber nicht viel.
Das hat es auf jeden Fall auch verdient, ASP.NET Core.
Es ist halt nicht so super gefragt, aber dafür sehr beliebt und wenn man sich das
hier anguckt, Leute, ohne Mist, warum nicht Svelte und ASP.NET Core Backend?
Klar, mit Svelte Kit kann man vieles auf Fullstack lösen, aber vielleicht will man
auch nicht sein komplettes Backend in Node schreiben und man braucht noch ein bisschen
was serverseitig, was wie man so schön sagt, das Heavy-Lifting macht.
Warum nicht in ASP.NET Core Backend und in Svelte oder Svelte Kit Frontend?
Da hat man eigentlich Poggers Technologie-Kombination.
Alternativ übertreffen könnte man das Ganze nur mit dem Rust-Backend.
Rust auf 4chan, es ist nicht nur Rust auf 4chan, überall ist die Rust-Taskforce aktiv
und lobt Rust und flamet alles andere.
Hyper ist ganz geil fürs Backend, kenne ich nicht.
Wo ist denn hier Hetzner?
Hat es nicht da drauf geschafft, okay.
Doch, Hetzner!
Hetzner ist sehr beliebt, guck mal.
Hetzner ist von den kleinen Cloud-Plattformen mit die beliebteste.
Cool eigentlich für die.
Es interessiert jetzt nicht so viele, wollen nicht so viele haben, aber die, die es kennen,
finden es gut.
Mario, das klingt mir nach einer richtig nicen Kombi, gerade weil du halt React hast und
du halt auch Leute findest für React und React halt das größte Ökosystem hat.
Das ist schon eine gute Kombination.
Du bist ein großer Sympathisant, das hört sich ja fast so an, als wäre ich irgendwie
keine Ahnung.
Wo sagt man das immer, so Sympathisant?
So halber Kult, genau, so halber Terrorist oder sowas.
Wie groß du bist, warum willst du das wissen?
Also ich bin ungefähr 1, so 1,74 in dem Dreh und wenn du auch wissen willst, was ich wiege,
sag ich dir auch, ich wiege 91 Kilo, also immer noch ein bisschen zu.
Ja, vielleicht noch einer, der mich auf der Arbeit erkannt hat.
Also ich hab nicht vor aufzuhören mit YouTube und Streaming.
YouTube ist gerade ein bisschen wenig, aber das hat wieder auch seine Phasen, sicher nicht,
wo es mehr wird.
Ich mach das ja auch nicht, weil ich damit Geld verdienen kann, großartig, aber nichts
also trotz Leute, gerade beim Thema Geld verdienen sind, solltet ihr im Besitz eines Prime Accounts
sein, spricht wenn ihr euer Twitch mit Amazon verknüpft habt und einen Prime Sub vergeben
könnt.
Da würde ich mich natürlich sehr drüber freuen, wenn ihr den mir gebt, aber es muss
nicht an mich sein, aber ihr solltet ihn nicht verfallen lassen, kann man glaube ich nicht
oft genug sagen.
Primers sind immer sehr nice, es ist auch schon, Kastellan, Dankeschön für den Sub,
Sly, Poggers Subscription, so mag ich das.
Es ist extremly nice, komm mal wieder in den ESP Bastel Stream, sollten wir echt mal
wieder machen.
Adelaise, Pog Subscription, oh jetzt kommt auch noch der Scam Train, Leute lasst euch
von Besos ne Runde scammen, der muss wieder ins Weltall fliegen oder sowas, das ist wichtig.
Hast du manchmal eine Plokade beim Programmieren oder gar keinen Bock mehr auf, ja, also Plokade
in dem Sinn, ich beiß mich da immer, würde ich nicht Plokade nennen, aber ich hab manchmal
einfach keinen Bock mehr an Projekten, wo ich gestern noch Bock drauf hatte, weiterzubauen
und dann hör ich einfach von heute auf morgen auf, selbst wenn das recht beliebt ist und
sogar auch Leute benutzen und sowas, hab ich einfach keinen Bock mehr.
MP84, Pog Subscription, nice.
Ja, schön, dass ihr alle da seid heute, ich sag euch aber gleich jetzt nur mal so, was
der weitere Plan ist, so in einer Viertelstunde spielen wir noch ein paar Runden Battlefield
2042, ich hab Bock noch ein paar Runden zu spielen und ich brauch noch ein bisschen Gameplay,
dass ich ein Video aufnehmen kann, so 10 Minuten, Viertelstunde, wenn ihr noch was wissen wollt,
IT-technisch hier, passend zur Umfrage oder sowas in der Richtung, was wir uns gerade
angeguckt haben oder überhaupt irgendwas technikbezogenes, habt ihr jetzt noch 10 Minuten
bis so Viertelstunde Zeit, das im Chat loszuwerden?
Max, Pog Subscription, nice.
Und Chat, einmal bitte für den Max eine Runde Mod-Check in, also hier, Mod-Check in den Chat,
weil der Max, der macht richtig exzellente Sachen, also alle Mods machen exzellente Sachen.
Allerdings möchte ich den Max jetzt trotzdem mal hervorheben, weil der zum Beispiel solche
coolen Sachen gebaut hat, wie das Wubbler's Archiv, wo aus irgendwelchen Gründen Webass
steht.
Der hat das Wubbler's Archiv gemacht, wo man meine ganzen Streams durchsuchen kann, man
sieht nicht nur die Worts und die Clips, man hat alle Streams, auch nach Jahresansicht
und sowas in der Richtung hier drinnen, aber das eigentlich Beste ist, ihr könnt Streams
durchsuchen nach einem Titel vom Video, von dem Stream und jetzt kommt der Hit, das hat
niemand auf der Welt, außer ich, oder außer der Max, ja, der es gebaut hat, sowas hat
kein anderer Streamer auf der Welt.
Ihr könnt alles, was ich gesagt habe, im Stream durchsuchen, also wenn ihr jetzt, wenn
ihr wissen wollt, wo ich über den Ultraskiller geredet habe, ja, dann gebt ihr Ultraskiller
ein und der kann alles Gesagte im Video durchsuchen und ich beantworte auch mal hier, dass das
funktioniert.
Schön, jedes Wort, was du je gesagt hast, kann man dir folgen, naja, gut, das ist eh
öffentlich.
Guck hier, Oldschool Ultraskiller, genau an der Stelle kommt man raus.
Wie das funktioniert ist folgendes, wir laden alle Worts, also was heißt wir, ich habe damit
nichts zu tun.
Jetzt werden alle Streams runtergeladen von Twitch und per Machine Learning, das heißt
das ist nicht so hundertprozentig korrekt, das Transkript aber schon relativ gut, durch,
per Machine Learning in der Cloud mit Grafikkarten prozesst und dann wird das Transkript bei
jedem Wort hochgeladen mit Timestamp.
Eigentlich sehr pfeifett, ja, also müsst ihr schon mal sagen, das ist wirklich nice,
also sowas hat sonst keiner.
So, ich musste gerade was lesen, okay, also weiter geht's.
Hast du schon mal Managed Azure Web, nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe dafür Google Cloud Run schon benutzt, um sowas zu machen.
Von der Endpunkte habe ich lange nichts mehr gehört.
Okay Leute, ich muss mich da mal kurz drauf einstimmen, dass wir uns jetzt eine Runde
Battlefield geben.
Extended.
Also wir geben uns jetzt nicht Pet Company.
Ja, magst du können, ich invite dich gleich.
So, ich muss jetzt erstmal die EA App starten, dann dürft ihr nicht gucken und ich muss
die Kategorie vom Stream umstellen.
Habt ihr eine gute Idee für einen Titel des Streams?
Hast du eine Empfehlung für einen guten höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch?
Hieb, hab ich dich auf, ja, warum nicht, oder versuch mal zu stream snipen, okay, also
ich habe die EA App auf, gut, wunderbar, alles funktioniert, seid wieder am Start.
Ja, so, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier, haben wir noch irgendwas übrig, gab es noch
irgendwelche Questions, die ich überlesen habe, erstmal kann ich in dem Fall nicht so
viel zu sagen.
Ne, ich glaub nicht.
Hat mir das Freund heute einen Bug erinnert, der Max macht das schon, alles klar.
So, dann müssen wir mal die Kategorie umstellen, hat jemand eine gute Idee für den Streamtitel?
Bin ja immer so unkreativ, mir on the fly sowas auszudenken.
Also Kategorie Battlefield 2042, hat ganze 963 Viewer, boah, richtiger Brenner hier auf
Twitch gerade.
Pains Champ, Pains Champ 2042, okay, safe.
Auf der Arbeit haben wir diverse Rechner, die abgerechnet wurden, habe ich den Jobmalder
nicht für GitHub Actions Agents gebraucht, die meisten GitHub Agents Runner lässt er
doch in der Cloud laufen, ich mein, manchmal ist es durchaus sinnig, ja, kann man lokal
gehostete Runner machen, aber ganz ehrlich, da würde ich nicht alte Rechner für verwenden,
das würde ich auf irgendeiner ESX Geschichte mitlaufen lassen, best Ager in Battlefield.
So, das ist eine gute Idee, das mache ich jetzt als Titel, ja, Battlefield 2041++,
das ist ein guter Titel, okay let's go Battlefield, auf geht's, zack zack, nein, joini, ey, geh
mal weg, warum sind eigentlich, jetzt mal ernsthaft, warum ist da so ein Shit, warum
sind nicht meine Games einfach direkt auf der Startseite?
Ja, man wird's nicht verstehen, ja doch, man versteht's, es macht Geld, du hast Anfrage
geschickt, warte mal, Anfrage ist raus, EA App, ja, da ist er doch, Origin war besser,
nee, Origin war auch Müll, ist beides richtiger Müll, ich weiß gar nicht, was ich bevorzuge,
EA App oder Origin, das einzige, was bei der EA App tatsächlich viel schlechter ist
als bei Origin, bei Origin konntest du noch so einen FPS-Counter einblenden lassen bei
allen Games, aber geht das nicht, ich meine, man kann sagen, Perf Overlay, Perf Overlay,
Draw FPS 1, da ich mal ein bisschen flexen kann mit meinem NASA Rechner, kann ich mitspielen,
nee, wir sind schon drei, ansonsten kommen wir in so ganz komische Lobbys rein, du kannst
versuchen zu stream snipen, so, Invite, Invite, lass mal gucken, ob der Invite überhaupt
funktioniert, das backt ja gerne mal etwas rum in diesem Spiel, weil da eigentlich fast
nichts funktioniert, warum wurde das jetzt nur mit übelstem Lag gesendet, der Invite?
Du hast nichts bekommen, also wie ihr gesehen habt, Leute, ich habe obviously keine Einladung
geschickt, hat das Spiel keine Hintergrundmusik, kann das sein, dass es keine Hintergrundmusik
hat, oder habe ich die, Moment, oder habe ich die ausgeschaltet, Sound, ah, ja, ich
habe die ausgeschaltet, weil der Soundtrack von dem Spiel Müll ist, ja, das sollte auch,
das sollte auch ausbleiben, Aufhieb, komm, an den Start, auf geht's, let's go, ist recent
players, pass auf, jetzt hat er mich gebatet und man sieht ihn nie wieder im Stream, hä,
Alter, das Spiel ist so im Arsch, keine Ahnung, ich kann ja auch nichts machen, also, ich
kann ja nur Invites schicken, kannst du mir beitreten, ja, aber ich will selbst Games
suchen und sowas, also ich probiere das jetzt nochmal, so, wenn es jetzt nicht funktioniert,
du siehst, ich habe dich eingeladen, ich kann da nichts dran ändern gerade, ich habe
dich, ich habe dich auf jeden Fall geändert hier, sieht man, da bist du ja, du stehst
ja sogar mal mit der Freundesliste drin, let's go, rutsch, wir müssen gleich mal schnell
checken, ob der Sound, ob die Soundlautstärke richtig ist, ich vermute, der Sound dürfte
jetzt ein bisschen zu laut sein, aber nachdem Windows immer rumwurstet an den Soundsettings,
weiß man halt nicht so genau, du siehst den Origin, ey, die Logik muss man nicht verstehen,
ey, angeblich hat er gerade was gesagt, das gibt es nicht, outdated, overrated, gebated,
übrigens so ein bisschen geklont sehen wir ja schon aus, ey, ich glaube, Lautstärke
ist ganz gut, Max, welches Level bist du eigentlich, Prestige, irgendwas, ho, wir sind Attacker,
Pogu, endlich mal, letztes Mal waren wir viel zu oft Defender und ich wette mit euch,
ich wette mit euch, nächste Runde, wisst ihr, welche Map nächste Runde wahrscheinlich
gleich kommt, Hourglass Defender, wartet's ab, ok, Lautstärke testen, kurz, ist gut,
bisschen laut, bisschen laut ist es glaube ich, bisschen laut, machen wir mal 38, 38
ist glaube ich ganz gut, so, ich glaube 38 ist ganz, Moment, ich muss die Bitrate noch
hochstellen, dass das Game auch gescheit aussieht, Output, 7, Apply, ja, geht hoch, nice, let's
go, ey, wir haben schon die Legehenne gemacht, ist es jetzt zu leise, ok, wir müssen das
Game mal kurz in Window-Modus versetzen, dann so verschieben, dass ich was sehe, übrigens
ist das nicht möglich, ok, so verschieben, dass ich was sehe, jetzt ins Game gehen und
mal ballern, nö, das ist eigentlich ganz ok, oder, passt eigentlich ganz gut, denke ich,
ich kann, ich kann, wenn ihr wollt, noch einen Ticken lauter machen, aber insgesamt ist eigentlich,
ich meine, da ist ja immer, da ist immer ein Schalldämpfer drauf gerade, ich glaube, das
ist ganz gut, so, ich glaube, das ist jetzt echt ganz gut, mit Bunny gehoppt, guck mal,
ich musste nix machen, ich musste nix machen, einfach, einfach, instant hier, einfach instant
Legehenne am Start, oh, was ist denn hier los, da ist was, wow, wow, wow, aua, lass
mich in Ruhe, man, Max, ich rette dich gleich, keine Sorge, ich probiere es mal, ich hoffe,
die sehen mich nicht, nice, Spritze in Pobbers, alles dead, nice, wow, was ist hier los, zweiter
Bildschirm wäre eine Idee für sowas, zweiter Bildschirm habe ich auf dem zweiten Rechner
dran, also Chat, jetzt könnt ihr es euch, ah ne, wir können schon weiter, Chat, jetzt
könnt ihr es euch überlegen, Lautstärke noch, Lautstärke gut oder einen Ticken runter,
ich glaube, es passt eigentlich ganz gut so, wir können es mal ausprobieren, wartet mal,
guckt mal, guckt mal, ich ballere jetzt ohne Schalldämpfer und rede dabei, ich glaube,
es ist ein ganz gutes Verhältnis, oh, Alter, jetzt ist es aber gut, kann jemand in Ruhe
Soundtest machen hier, oh, Max macht Flank-Action, da gehe ich jetzt mit, Pog-Flank-Stells, nice,
Slidern, rein Sliden hier, oh, ne, nicht ins Aus Sliden, schlechte Idee, ganz schlechte
Idee hier, das Map aus zu Sliden, die werden jetzt schön abgefarmt hier, warum hat das
so geleckt gerade, habt ihr das auch gesehen, oh, oh, oh, hoffentlich, Nate, Nate, Nate,
fuck it, Alter, das Game wollte nicht, dass ich da drüber springe, ja, dead game, weißt
du, was bei Dr.Kamoum geht, ehrlich gesagt, ne, lange nichts gehört, also zuletzt hat
er bei einem größeren deutschen Automobilkonzern gearbeitet und war da richtig, richtig big
in den Marketing-Stonks unterwegs, Rest, keine Ahnung, lange nichts gehört, Max, ich kann
da gerade nicht hin, dead game, Spritze in den Arm, ist man selbstverständlich vollständig
gehealt, so, jetzt mal, hab mich getroffen, jetzt müssen wir hier mal durch, jetzt müssen
wir mal lang, oh, oh, oh, fuck, shit, ok, wenn ich, der Typ da oben hat die beste Posie
ever, richtige High IQ Position, vielleicht krieg ich nen Rez, ne, scheiße, hier kommen
so viele Granaten, das wird nix, der hat die richtige High IQ Position, der hat einfach
gerade 3 Leute weggerotzt am Stück, das muss ich mir merken, dass man von da oben reingucken
kann, wir sollten es mal, wir sollten es mal von nem anderen Weg ausprobieren, nicht immer
in die gleiche Richtung, das ist dann zu easy für die Leute, wir gehen, wir gehen
lieber, wir gehen lieber, ja, das ist nice, wir gehen lieber direkt, oh, da kommt was,
Achtung, Achtung, gebashed werdet ihr jetzt, wallbang mate, ok, das geht in dem Game nicht,
auch sehr gut, nix da, nix da, ok, äh, kann man da hoch, nein, nein, nein, ok, ok, shit,
den hab ich nicht gesehen, da war mein Duder vor, hab ich nicht mitbekommen, Team, please,
lasst mich nicht im Stich, wo liegen wir denn hier rum, ich glaub wir sollten trotzdem von
hier gehen, das andere, das andere sind die zu sehr, shit, ey, what, vielleicht, vielleicht,
vielleicht, der, daddy84, vielleicht kapiert er das, please, please, oh, Max MVP am Start,
nicht nur Poggers Modge, auch Poggers Medic, ich seh hier nix gerade, ok, der stirbt nicht,
also wie ich den kenne, guckt der immer noch gerade aus, guck, ha, ha, lol, lol wie ich's
wusste, dass der einfach weiter gerade ausguckt und hier links kommt jetzt gleich einer, shit,
man muss übrigens seit dem Patch, muss man ein bisschen, ein bisschen Tab schießen mit,
mit den, mit den Assault Rifles und es gibt nen Bug, es gibt nen Bug bei den Assault Rifles,
und zwar, ich aim das mal kurz ab hier, und zwar, der Burst, der Burst resettet nicht mehr,
der kommt gleich um die Ecke, da muss ich, da kann ich, da kann ich nicht hin, oh,
von hinten, in der Ass, in der Ass geschootet, daddy is dead, ja, ok, ok, vielleicht kann ich
daddy retzen, ne, jetzt hat daddy released, warum macht daddy denn sowas, ok, ach, oh man,
game, please, funktioniert doch einfach, ja, also es gibt nen Bug mit den Assault, mit den Assault
Rifles, aber es heißt Bug, sagt ja schon einer im Chat, das war schon immer so, das kann sein,
aber normalerweise, also, Assault Rifles haben mit dem Patch mehr, mehr Recoil und Bullet Spread
bekommen, so, die, die wollen, dass man mit den Assault Rifles so schießt, das Problem ist,
wenn du mit den Assault Rifles so schießt, der, der Spread resettet sich nicht, du bist dann auf
dem, du bist dann auf dem Dude drauf, aber du triffst ihn nicht, das ist einfach nur komplett
lächerlich, Max, ich hol dich, oh ne, ich hol dich nicht, da ist ne Granate auf dir drauf,
ok, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, Spritze in Pommes wieder, nice, aua, so ein bisschen Gegner,
wir haben nur noch 28 Tickets, Leute, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go, jetzt müssen wir uns,
jetzt müssen wir uns aber richtig beeilen, wir müssen uns richtig sputen, alle dead,
gell, alter, shit, die stehen da aber auch gut drinnen, Team, Team, please, ok, wir machen jetzt
mal richtige, richtige YOLO-Aktion, aus irgendwelchen Gründen, shit, man kann da nicht durchschießen,
muss man verstehen, so ein bisschen Holz ist schon, oh ne, shit, ich kann da nicht rein spawnen,
spawnge, spawnge, please, out of combat, ok, wo sind, wo, ich weiß nicht, wo wir sind,
wo sind wir denn, ah, ok, ok, Leute, ich probiere es nochmal, hier ist nix, hier ist nix, ok, noch
10 Tickets, wir müssen jetzt ran, Leute, wir müssen jetzt ran, 10 Tickets, die Noobs verlieren die
Tickets, Leute, die Noobs fliegen nicht in Heli, die Noobs verlieren die Tickets, wir müssen ran,
wir müssen ran, what, der lebt da oben, warum lebt denn der, kann doch nicht sein, der lebt doch,
nein, wir waren so close dran, Max, an uns lag es definitiv nicht, kann man glaube ich so sagen,
oder, Poggers Support mit Medic, meisten Kills gemacht, also wir können da wirklich nichts für,
dass wir die Runde verloren haben, du lagst deadge vorm M-Com, dazu kann ich sagen, deadge vorm M-Com
ist ziemlich sadge, ich möchte nochmal betonen, dieser Satz hat gerade ein fast 39-Jähriger gesagt,
der hier vor seinem Rechner sitzt und Battlefield spielt, mein typisches Vokabular für 39-Jährige,
würde ich sagen, deadge ist sadge, du findest, die Portal-Waffen klingen leider immer noch wie
Airsoft-Waffen, ok, nein, das stimmt nicht, ich bin nicht 39, ich bin 38, ich bin erst in ein paar
Monaten 39, die Portal-Waffen, ich meine, für Boomer Opa immer noch die meisten Kills der Runde,
kann man sich trotzdem gefallen lassen, oder, man könnte den Titel des Streams auch machen,
alter Boomer und junge Tryhards, oder sowas, wobei, dann könnte sich jemand darüber lustig,
ah, da ist er ja, guck mal, hat funktioniert, der Heap ist am Start, dann könnte sich aber jemand
drüber lustig machen, wenn ich die Runde massacke, was durchaus auch vorkommt, wie gesagt, gerade
PPGa-Aim-Time extrem, aber ich spiele einfach zu wenig FPS in letzter Zeit, oder generell zu
wenig Aim-lastige Spiele, ist ja nicht wirklich so, dass Battlefield jetzt das Ultra-Aim erfordern
würde, aber man muss halt schon irgendwie auf den Gegner mit dem Fadenkreuz, du hast einen
Arbeitskollegen, der auch mit Twitch-Emotes spricht, das ist nice, so Leute hätte ich auch
gerne, das einzige Mal, dass ich bei der alten Arbeit war, dass ich aber noch ein Twitch-Emote
gehört habe, war, da gab es irgendeine Präsentation, so, was denkt ihr zu diesem Thema,
und dann, da haben die so einen Slide gemacht, wo man abstimmen konnte, und da habe ich, also,
wo man reinschreiben konnte, wie man das findet, und das dann hochvoten, und da habe ich reingeschrieben
Poggers, und irgendjemand von den Manager-Leuten wussten, glaube ich, nicht, was das ist, und haben
dann gesagt, ah, ich sehe hier Poggers, Poggers, die wussten halt absolut nicht, was sie da vorlesen,
aha, hier eine Reaktion, Poggers, ganz schön Poggers, Leute, oder? Ach ja, und dass sich die Waffen aus dem
World immer noch anhören, wie Plastik und so, naja, ich muss sagen, das ganze Game hat nichts, also,
wird nicht dem Battlefield-Soundanspruch gerecht, das reiht sich aber gut ein, weil das ganze Spiel
wird eigentlich fast nichts am Battlefield gerecht, so, eine Runde Bunny gehoppe, und ich finde, wenn
man jemand, alter, ja, ist klar, guck mal, warum sind, ey, was ist das für ein M-Complacement, alter,
was ist das für ein M-Complacement, guck mal, was ist das für ein M-Complacement, wir sind volle
Pulle gespawnt und reingerennt als Defender, ne, und wir sind nicht an dem fucking M-Com gewesen,
bevor die Attacker dran waren, was ist das für ein M-Complacement, das ist absolut kompletter
PPGA-Shit, das war ultra PPGAim of Doom, das war krass, PPGAim ever, wuii, spawn, gell, auf der Map
habe ich letzten schon so PPGAim mit der PPGA29, wir machen jetzt hier auf CS, wir prefiren in die
Smokes rein, oh, fuck, komm raus, komm raus, oh, der Sack, nice, oh, shit, shit, dead, dead, dead, wenn er dead ist,
kommen wir nicht mehr ran an B, richtig, warum können die spawnen und ich nicht, Anzeige, was
sollen das, nice, schön, genau diesen Mast, den wollte ich treffen, das war exactly mein Plan,
ok, hier kommt nichts lang, oder, Achtung, damit habt ihr nicht gerechnet, ne, beste Angles, gebashed,
würde ich da mal sagen, ok, wenn wir Glück haben, ist jetzt hier noch einer drin, wo ist hier was,
wow, man, alter, die sind immer so aggressiv, ich verstehe das überhaupt nicht, Hieb, ich muss zum M kommen,
ok, sorry, nein, ich muss nicht zum M kommen, ich bin dead, dead, aber sowas von dead, gell, und ich glaube auch mal,
das war es jetzt mit dem M kommen, wenn wir Glück haben, kommen wir noch in die nächste Zone rein,
so dass wir nicht gleich gekickt, also nicht gleich gekillt werden für out of bounds sein,
ja, ne, wobei ich sagen muss, also die M-Comps hier auf Discard finde ich auch sehr schwierig,
jetzt seit dem M-Comp Replacement, oder Neu-Placement, oder schießt irgendwie was von links,
wo kommt hier was her, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, die sind einfach straight durchgeflogen,
war das ein, war das ein LMG, moin, war das ein LMG, ist dieses Avanci-Dings, ist das ein LMG,
LMG Legit, oh, da ist ganz schön viel los, ich muss mich mal hier kurz ganz schnell verpissen,
ja, ist es, ich sollte mal ein bisschen mehr LMGs anlocken, weil im Ernst, LMGs sind,
glaube ich, echt ganz nice, seit dem Assault-Rifle-Nerf, das war doch, das war doch einfach nur
Luck, dass der gehittet hat, oder, ja, klar, nicht sterben, please, by the way, Burst-Fire,
by the way, so, irgendwas war da doch eben noch dahinter, ihr habt es doch genau gesehen,
da stehen sie auf dem Berg, da kann ich jetzt nicht so wirklich contesten, wir gehen mal wieder
rüber, weil es ist keiner an den M-Comps, ne, niemand ist wirklich an den M-Comps und ich sehe
schon, da drüben ist alles vollgesmokt, die sind, die sind bestimmt gleich am Start und,
guck hier, guck hier, da wird schon, da ist schon was, du wirst sehen, da drüben sind schon die
ersten, war, war, war so klar, ist das ein Spawn-Beacon, Leute, ich höre hier 30.000 Gegner,
aber ich sehe keinen, da unten war aber einer, hier war auch einer, okay, pass mal auf,
oh, Alter, hab ich ein Glück, dass ich den zweiten Shot gehittet habe, das war wirklich glücklich,
dass, dass ich die, hör auf zu schießen, dass ich die Shotgun mit am Start habe, sehr lucky,
oh, ne, ich dachte, kann auch in Deckung gehen, war die Frage, ob du was von Kaboom gehört hast,
ja, hab ich beantwortet, ne, hab ich nicht, schon, ist schon bestimmt zwei Jahre her,
oh, wenn wir Glück haben, können wir beim Max spawnen, ich hoffe, da geht nicht,
ein exzellenter Mod, oh, von der Seite, Boris, oh, oh, Rats, ha, nice, die haben wir gebasht,
und, oh, hier links, pass auf, pass auf, hier sind einige, hier sind einige am Start,
oh, da sind noch mehr, okay, Max, ich probiere es einfach mal, okay, jetzt ist natürlich die
Frage, okay, können wir hier lang, oder sollten wir besser, wir sollten besser ein bisschen in
Deckung laufen, mal hier Türen zumachen, ich höre links, ich höre links ganz viele,
sehr, sehr faires 3D-Spotting, wieder, da wird umlaufen, da benutzen wir mal unseren Ente-Haken,
oh, Pog in the Kop, war da im Busch einer, Leute, shit, das Ding, dieses SK-Ding, SKR oder so,
was der da hat, das macht schon echt krassen Damage, ne, oh, oh, oh, was ist denn da,
da war doch irgendeiner gerade, okay, pass auf, pass auf, wir sind jetzt, ich habe da oben einen
gesehen, wir sind jetzt mal richtig, die kriegen ja mal richtig auf den Sack gerade die Gegner,
so, oh, oh, die pushen aber gut ran gerade, Puschke, Puschke, hör doch mal auf, warum treffen
die was, die, es gibt, Leute, ich sage euch, es gibt einfach kaum noch richtige Noobs,
die sind, die sind heute alle besser als noch vor 15 Jahren, was ja auch logisch ist, ne,
ich meine, die hatten Zeit, 15 Jahre zu üben, by the way, warum verlieren die das letzte Ticket
nicht, was ist denn hier los, jawoll, nice, okay, Leute, GG Eats, im Gegnerteam sind IHK-Prüfer,
ja, so spielen sie echt, die fragen erstmal die Osi-Schichten ab, bevor es richtig losgeht,
also bevor ich jetzt das M-Com lege, was ist, was ist denn bitteschön Osi-Layer 2,
ah, falsche Antwort, ne, dann wird jetzt nicht gelegt, probiere mal die AC9, das SMG,
find die OP, okay, probiere ich aus, muss ich aber mal gucken, was für eine Map nächstes Mal
drankommt und ich glaube, für die habe ich auch noch nix unlockt, habe ich die überhaupt,
lass mal kurz gucken, AC9, was war das, wow, Alter, was war das für ein Matchmaking,
Instant Matchmaking, sind auf einmal wieder 50.000 Spieler am Start, please attacker,
please attacker, please attacker, okay, habe ich die AC, du meinst nicht die,
ah nee, SMG, ah, hier die da, was sind wir, Attacker, Leute, für die erste Base kann ich
das nicht spielen, ich schreibe es mir aber auf, für die erste Base muss ich die beste Waffe
spielen, weil die Map ist verbuggt, äh, Game, die Map ist verbuggt und zwar folgendes, die
Map ist verbuggt und zwar die Attacker-Boote respawnen nicht richtig, was ziemlicher Müll
ist, ja, man sieht sehr viel, dankeschön, was richtiger Müll ist, da du deswegen, oh shit,
ich musste mal kurz rausspringen, äh, da du deswegen halt einfach nicht richtig attacken
kannst, oh nice, nice, okay, ich muss schnell, schnell, schnell, ja, scheiße, ich habe nicht
die Attachments drauf, Vorgas und ich habe veraimt, beides in Kombination, äußerst keck,
wait, geiler Satz, Max, äußerst keck, wait, ja, was war das, was mich da gerade gekillt hat,
ein Rack, ah, da liegt, alter, was ne Pose, Mann, okay, ich bin froh, dass mein Team so
Pog ist, weil, au, dass mein Team so Pog ist, weil ich bin gerade nicht Pog, aber das muss ja
auch mal so sein, ne, und die LLV-Sacken, die sind einfach nur mies, seit, oh, oh, oh, die
Anti-Air, die Anti-Air, gib Anti-Air, Anti-Air, Anti-Air, ich brauche das Ding, lass mich, lass
mich zur Anti-Air, nein, alter, damit hätten wir die jetzt so zerfickt, wenn wir noch die
Anti-Air gekriegt hätten von denen, sag mal, ist das ein Stream-Sniper oder ist das einfach nur
unglaublich Pech, dass der mich raketet die ganze Zeit, oh, warum gehen wir hier gerade so buttermäßig
durch, das ist sehr nice, es ist nicht so, als will ich mich beschweren, easy, easy, richtig easy,
ich bleib mal hier kurz ein bisschen in Deckung, guck mal, ob da noch irgendeiner vorgerannt kommt
vielleicht, nein, alter, easiest, easiest Nosharkennels überhaupt, äh, GG-Game, sehr gut gemacht,
genau so war das geplant, okay, wir können gehen, ich bin begeistert, ich muss nichts machen die
Runde, ich bin einfach voll am abkacken und wir gewinnen trotzdem easy, 23-0, Hieb, was geht
mit dir ab, Keg, wait, alter, bist du Heli, bist du im Heli oder wie geht das, ist, ist, ist da, ist
da Raketen-Rolf jetzt, der mich wieder, der mich wieder raketen will, ich sehe keine Gegner, haben
die schon, haben die schon einfach Rage, Rage quittet, Rage quittet, ich glaube, die haben, ich
glaube, die haben alle Rage quittet schon, direkt, direkt leave, instant, instant quitt, Hieb ist im
Heli, deswegen hat der Typ so viele Kills, okay, easy, easy win, jeder Map, wir haben Hieb, der
Heli fliegt, dann ist das kein Problem, easy win, easy win, der, der rockt das alles hier, der macht
das easy, das ist gar kein, da müssen, da müssen wir gar nichts machen, gg, MLG, MLG legit, Pilot, ja, okay,
mal schauen, ob wir hier schnell drüber kommen, äh, game, so war das nicht geplant, au, au, lass mich in
Ruhe, oh shit, ich war dumm, ich bin schon rüber gelaufen, über zehn Sekunden Counter und dann war
es halt richtig, richtig blöd, nice, wir spawnen jetzt beim Hieb rein, jumpen hier einfach runter, so, nice, easy,
Rangflieger, moin, was ist denn hier los, warum sterbt ihr hier, warum wird hier, warum wird hier,
äh, einer auf, auf dead gear gemacht, au, au, au, au, au, au, au, au, au, au, kick, kick, ha, kick, leis, kick, wait, man,
der LLB-Fahrer, man, oh shit, den anderen hätte ich gehabt, der LLB-Fahrer kam sich auch ein bisschen
verarscht vor oder?
Aber unser Heli ist halt richtig OP
wir gewinnen jede Map
es sei denn die Gegner haben
ups
ah der hat die SMG am Start
ok ich probier jetzt doch mal die SMG
aus Leute
wir scheinen die Runde ja eh easy zu gewinnen
da kann ich auch mal SMG
legit spielen
ich hab halt nichts unlockt für die
ok die schießt schön schnell
ist halt ne SMG
ne SMG
wir bräuchten jetzt hier eigentlich ein bisschen
Range Weapon aber wir haben unseren Heli
stellst du da mal
oh oh oh
ok nice
ok die ist nice mit der kann man übelst auf Range
sprayen
fast besser als mit nem Assault Rifle
Leute
ich muss hier unten rein, pass mal auf
ich zeig euch jetzt den Schleichweg
den Schleichweg über Noshar Canals
das geht aber nur solange man nicht gespottet ist
sobald man gestream sniped
oder gespottet ist, ist man dead
und dann am besten
alle sterben und die Leute rein
spawnen lassen
ne das ist der beste Weg
sei denn man ist gespottet
beste
ich geh jetzt rein
keiner da, guck
keiner da Leute
einfach keiner da
jetzt müssen wir eigentlich nur gucken
dass hier keiner rüberkommt
und wir gehen schon mal in Posi
dass wir woanders hin können, die andere Seite wechseln
Achtung, Pantsman am Start
nein nein
lass mich in Ruhe
ok mit der LMG muss ich noch ein bisschen aufpassen
achtung
Poppes
ok wir haben es, nice
hoffentlich
kommt da jetzt gleich noch was
haben die Gegner nicht auch
nen Tank?
oh wir haben schon Legehennen gemacht
oh was ist hier, lass mich in Ruhe
gehst du weg
geh weg
ok nice, gute Posi
excellent
der Typ ist richtig lost
der ist richtig lost
der Fahrer
easy, alter
das war die einfachste
Nosharkennels Attacker Runde die ich je gespielt hab
Heap hat einfach mal
45-1 mit dem Heli
das liegt aber auch daran
weil, guckt euch das mal an
niemand hat Anti-Air
irgendwas gespielt, die haben Sniper
gespielt, Medic, ein paar haben Engineer
gespielt, ein paar, aber hätten die mal
ordentlich Heli gegeiert
ach haben die
Heli gegeiert, ok dann
alles gut
das ist gut, dass du am Start bist, da gewinnen
wir einfach jede Map, wo es Helis gibt
was hältst du
von der Runde, weil Paraiso
Paraiso, falls es jetzt kommt
und dann fliegen wir nicht Heli, da fliegen wir
alle in diesem
in diesem
wie heißt denn das Ding
in diesem schweren
Transport Heli, ja das meine ich
das was man
in Blackhawk Helicopter
im Original war, weil es jetzt dieser komische
Osprey Gunner oder was das ist
ist, ja
ok, was haben wir denn hier unlockt
ich muss mal kurz in meine Collection
diese komische
SMG auswählen, was haben wir denn hier
Griff, Curiosity while moving
Curiosity while static
braucht keiner
40 und
keine Ahnung, Hauptsache
was haben wir hier
sonst, oh
Minimap Suppression, sehr schön, sehr gut
das machen wir
da können wir nämlich ein bisschen
Moment, stand da 40 Meter plus
ne 40 Meter plus
für die SMG bringt mir nichts, ich brauch wirklich
Minimap Stealth, wenn ich dran bin
ansonsten ist das
nicht so nice
at 40 meters
ja das ist doof, dann brauch
ich das auch nicht
lass ich das einfach runter
mach dir die Sachen auf den ersten
Spot, da hast du recht
aber mach ich trotzdem nicht
aber du hast recht
das machen wir nicht
Curiosity while moving, POG
mehr Schuss, alles gut
was ist denn da der Unterschied
Leute ich seh keinen Unterschied
ach der Punkt
ist anders
ah dann, Poggers Punkt
Giga Aim
Leute, Giga Aim
Wow
Alter hat er mich weggelasert gerade
in den Ass
der hat mich gerade mal richtig weggeklatscht
oh wir
wir werden gerade ziemlich
ziemlich destroyed
ok jetzt müssen wir
jetzt müssen wir aufpassen, ich stell's
mich jetzt ein bisschen hier rum und gucke
wenn was kommt und wenn was kommt
werden sie gebashed
ok
ich mein wir haben ja nur noch A
mach dir
was ist da unten
Max ich komm da gerade nicht hin
lebt der da unten noch oder ist der dead
ich muss noch eine Runde campen
es geht jetzt nicht anders
oh ich hör ganz viele, ganz viele dudes
bei uns hier rumlaufen
oh shit
nope
wo bin ich jetzt hier, geile beste
Posi ever, da muss man hin
hier ist das
Klitsch
Outplayed this game
ich bin kein SMGs mehr gewöhnt
bin viel zu lahm
Alter das lasert
das ist schon ganz schön für das
dass es so eine range hat
du wurdest noob tooped, ich hol dich Max, passt schon
Spritze in Pobbers
weiter gehts
oh shit
ich hör da unten
low ammo
oh no
no
oh wie schlecht, ich sacke so krass mit
ich sacke so krass mit
SMGs
absoluter Wahnsinn
was die sind nicht dead
shit
oh das ist close
da sind ganz schön viele dran, wir müssen uns jetzt beeilen
schnell rauf
und hopp
damit hätte der jetzt nicht gerechnet
Shotgun in your face
ok mal kurz gucken was da unten kommt
nix, auch gut
ok
next
ok komm wir pushen da mal raus
alter welche
ich bin so schlecht mit
SMGs, nein
ok ah ich kann hier nicht
ratzen
ok
ich muss mich mal kurz verpissen hier
auf range
ist der damage dropoff bisschen zu
krass
ich glaube ich mach den Schalldämpfer ab
oh alter
der Max ist mal
hyper aggressive hier
der ist ja fast schon gachi bass
drin
ich mach den Schalldämpfer
ab, brauchen wir doch hier eh nicht
die wissen doch eh
dass ich da bin
die wissen doch eh dass ich da bin
Max lass es, da liegt direkt eine Granate auf mir drauf
ok nice
Pog, PP
gerade aimed, SMG, alles klar
aber trotzdem easy gewonnen
3 gescheite Leute am Start
schon geht das
ok wir können jetzt chat
Braige, wir brauchen mal kurz
Braige für den RNG
dass wir Valparaiso bekommen
Braige
die war nicht das erste Squad, so gehts aber nicht
jetzt kommt Hourglass gleich
der hat diesen
der hat den Condor
Valparaiso
Condor leider Trash
ah
warum ist Condor Trash
looks like
noch mal
ok nice
na dann, ne ich spiel jetzt nicht
an die SMGs muss ich mich
jetzt erstmal wieder gewöhnen
ich aime zu PP-ger mäßig
gerade für
nicht long range
mittlere range, bisschen langsamer
weil im Nahkampf muss der wirklich
äh
das Ding könnten wir auch mal wieder rausholen
oder
lass mal kurz gucken
ACR M416, komm wir nehmen das Teil mal wieder
wieder Attacker
Pog
jetzt wieder Leute
in your face
mal gucken ob das jetzt
wieder easiest Nosharkennels Runde
überhaupt wird, ne passt alles
geht mir nicht
weg hier
wow
ich hatte noch mal Glück gehabt, ich dachte ich bin drüber
rausgeschossen
da ist er, hieb am Start, jawoll
direkt den Heli gekrabbt, easy win
wir machen das
wir machen das hier on ground
so lang, oh, alter
exzellent
Max da sind noch mehr
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
jawoll
sehr nice
ok, jetzt müssen wir mal kurz bisschen langsamer
was ist denn da?
hab ich da Gegner gesehen?
shit, shit
ich dachte nicht dass ich es mitkriege, fuck
ich dachte wir können uns da drüber
drüber stelzen und
ah ok
benutzen wir gerade mal den Heli zum rein spawnen
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
ich hätte auch
auf dem Dach landen sollen, Leute
Dach, Dach landen
beste, da war was
egal, den schnappen wir uns jetzt hier
den Dude
äh, ok
null
Max hast du gelegt
eine nice Legehenne vollführt
woah
schlechte Idee
zu reloaden
ist Nosha Kennels auch im Hauptspiel?
ja
in der normalen Rush Rotation ist
Nosha, Nosha Kennels gerade
in der normalen Rush Rotation
Max ich rette dich gleich
ich leg noch schnell
ah das ist gar nicht der Max
die sehen mich nicht
oh das ist ein Panzer
ich hab so ein bisschen Schiss
gerade hier raus zu gehen
aber irgendwie
irgendwie sind keine Gegner da
wo sind die?
ok
alles gut, alles gut
alles gut
ich, ich bestehe nicht
ich bestehe nicht drauf, dass Gegner da sind
alles dead, ok
da geh ich nicht raus
alter die
Nosha Kennels Runde geht wieder ab
3 Sekunden, let's go
shit, zu früh
aber ähm
Wesker, freu dich nicht zu früh
Nosha Kennels ist verbuggt
woah
alter
wie der leckt
habt ihr gesehen, wie der krass, wie der Dude geleckt ist
ah, fuck, veraimt
äh, habt ihr gesehen, wie der Typ geleckt ist
achja, ähm
Nosha Kennels ist verbuggt
die Attackerboote respawnen nicht richtig
du kannst Attacker eigentlich gar nicht gewinnen
es sei denn, du hast halt so einen nice
Heli
Pilot am Start
ok
nice
wir campen jetzt mal die hier kurz ab
und protecten das
ok
jetzt können wir rüber gehen
können wir rüber gehen
oh, da kommt noch was von der Seite
da kommt noch was von der Seite
der will hier hinten
so nett
auch wenn fast alle down sind
oh, da hinten ist ein Panzer
ach, das sind meine
das erkennt man manchmal
so schlecht
wenn es overlayt, ist ok, wir müssen
da mal hin in die Richtung
oh
ich hab
jetzt überfährt er mich einfach
von hinten, alter
das resettet halt einfach nicht richtig
ok, 5 Sekunden
let's go, let's push
in der Hoffnung, da hat sich nicht hinten einer in die Ecke gekämpft
was sie gerne machen
ok
pass mal auf, was wir jetzt machen
wir fahren mit
es hat geleckt, habt ihr gesehen?
Mikroruckler
ich glaub, die sind alle dead
wie sieht denn bitte der Silencer aus?
der sieht ziemlich pepo-fett aus
mein Gott, die kriegen aber gerade mal
wieder auf den Sack, alter
was ist hier?
ok, ich kämpf mal eine Runde hier oben drauf
falls da einer reinkommt gleich
die müssen ja hier reinkommen
oh, oh, gehst du weg?
Panzman?
Panzers?
geh dir mal please weg
ich hoffe, wir haben es gleich
war da hinten noch was?
hab ich nicht gesehen
alter
Hieb macht die so kalt
da haben wir es
gleich doppelt so einfach auf dem Boden
hier sieht man übrigens gerade, wie der Recoil
nicht gesettet hat, trotz Burst
Moin Max, was hältst du von BattleBit?
ich hab vor ein paar Tagen tatsächlich
BattleBit
ah man
BattleBit gespielt im Stream
ehm, ehrlich gesagt
ich glaube, das Game wird keinen Erfolg
haben als Early Access Pay Titel
mit 15€, nicht dass
15€ krass viel wäre für
ein Game
ja, geiler, oh, oh
der ist ausgestiegen, oder?
aber ich glaube
den Hype hat
das Game, weil es Free2Play ist und so ein bisschen
Battlefield Lite, ansonsten
es hat mir nicht so richtig
zugesagt
Dankeschön Game
ich finde nicht, dass solche Games mit so einem
Grafikstil schlecht sind, ganz im Gegenteil
ich mag ja eigentlich so minimalistischen Kram
aber nichtsdestotrotz
finde ich, ist die Grafik
zu
detailarm
und ich meine damit so, dass auf den Maps
nichts rumsteht
alter
und
dass die
teilweise
keine richtigen Schattenwürfe haben
ich kriege keine Kills heute
ich darf die alle damagen, aber es gibt dann
keine Kills
Kill ist overrated, outdated, shebaited
oh, ich reloade
gerade
ok, ich muss mal kurz Ammo wechseln
20, was habe ich da jetzt
für einen Schrott geladen?
wie soll man mit 20 Schuss was killen?
manch einer
würde jetzt sagen, Max, da musst du halt treffen
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
aber treffen ist ziemlich overrated
in dem Game
Moment, let's go
nein, oh, oh, oh, oh
es wird knapp
es wird an uns extremst
vorbeigesniped
kann ich wieder meinen alten Schuss
verwenden? ja, viel besser
so, was haben wir denn hier? guck mal da hinten
was ist mit dir los?
au
aber easy reds für unsere Leute
bis jetzt, ja
ok
ok, wir machen wieder unsere Stelzrute, Leute
wobei der Max ist ja schon fast dran
der Max ist ja schon fast am
Ammo
wie hat er denn das so schnell gemacht?
kann das sein, dass wir einfach nur
mega
lahm gewesen sind?
der Max macht das gerade im Alleingang
oh
siehste?
vielleicht kann ich bei Max spawnen
wenn ich Glück hab
wenn er noch nicht in Combat ist
nee, kann ich nicht
das ist sehr risikoreich mit dem Boot
hier hinten rumzufahren
das endet dann so
oh, nicer spawn
spawn, spawn, spawn, spawn
boah, krass, boah, krass
ey, ey, was ist das hier?
warum sieht er uns?
wir waren offiziell
ich hab gerade extra Dice angerufen
wir waren offiziell nicht sichtbar
ich zeig euch gleich die Mail
Ban ist übrigens schon raus
ja
dein Vater arbeitet auch bei Dice?
nice
also mein Vater
hat früher bei Microsoft gearbeitet
der konnte dann immer die Leute bei Xbox Live
bannen, wenn ich ihn gefragt hab
und jetzt arbeitet er bei Dice
shit, PP geaimt
und ich muss mal aufhören
dauernd zu releasen
ich bin es nicht gewöhnt mit Teammates zu spielen, die mich retzen
oh, Max
ich versuch dich mal zu holen
shit, dead
aber wir haben es, wir haben es
oh, da ist eigentlich ein Dude gerade reingesprungen
ich dachte es ist ein Kopf
nein, da wollte ich nicht hoch
wollte eigentlich hier rüber
in der Hoffnung, dass da keiner rüber guckt
ist er dead?
die sind aber aggressiv gerade drauf
die Gegner
die letzte Base ist auch mega
die ist
die letzte Base ist mega schwer
oh shit
Pants Man
geh weg
big ass tank, ja
ok, ok
Achtung
shit, ich wollte ihm den Fuß wegschießen
woher soll ich wissen, dass da einer an der fucking
Gatling Gun steht
holt mich nicht, holt mich nicht Leute, holt mich nicht
ok
BAM, du Sack
richtig in die Fresse geballert mit der Shotgun
so muss das sein, mir egal ob ich gestorben bin
der hat es verdient
der hat es verdient, der Typ
und jetzt easy win
so mag ich das, so
finde ich das nice
so ist das, also wenn wir nicht Top Squad
waren Leute, dann weiß
ich auch nicht
der Max hat Objective geplayt, ich hab
Crown gekillt, Heap hat Crown und
Heap hat Crown gekillt
also passt mal auf, wenn wir nicht Top Squad
sind, ja, ok, ok
also alles andere
wäre ja auch schon wirklich sehr mega gewesen
gerade, aber bei dem Battlefield
Ranking weiß man nie
excellent, wann haben wir denn eigentlich
die G36, wir haben die
G36 gerade unlockt, ne
jetzt, jetzt haben wir sie unlockt
die wird jetzt gleich ausprobiert
da war ich nämlich die ganze Zeit schon drauf
ob die was taugt oder nicht
Keck, Keck W
ne ich hab sie noch nicht
Sätke
da war ich, da war ich nämlich drauf
Keck, Keck W 46
ne
es ist ne G36, aber sie heißt halt anders
weil die sich wieder keine Waffenrechte kaufen wollten
taugt Battlefield ein bisschen was
ja
es ist aber alles trotzdem noch sehr
verbuggt, das Spiel ist auf
Sport und wenn du es, wenn du Geld
dafür aufgegeben hast, dann
guck dir das mal an
wenn du es erst kaufen willst, dann guck mal
dass du es vielleicht im Sale oder irgendwie so kriegst
also Vollpreis 60€ würde ich
wirklich nicht dafür ausgeben, wenn du halt
unbedingt sagst, ey ich würde mal wieder gern
Battlefield spielen und auch irgendwie mal ein neues
wieder, weiß ich noch nicht, gespielt haben, du hast es noch nicht
warte auf einen Sale, ich würde, ich würde
denen wirklich keine, keine Kohle für das geben
jetzt nochmal Vollpreis, was die da
was die da abgeliefert haben
was kommt denn für ne Map, ich hab gar nicht
geguckt, Orbital
Orbital Defender
oh, das ist auch so ein Ding
ich finde die erste
M-Com Base ist so
naja, du hast als Defender
ganz gute Chancen, wenn du es sofort
schaffst hier oben an den
an den Berg zu kommen, dann geht das halbwegs
da kannst du, da kannst du so
die ersten paar Wellen
auscampen
EA Play ist auch ne gute Sache, wenn man noch
teilweise spielt, ja das stimmt, aber wir sind sehr weit
hinten gespawnt
ok, mal gucken, mal gucken ob wir da oben in die
Ecke kommen
oh shit
das wollte ich gar nicht, wollte eigentlich mich
you dead?
aren't?
alter
wollt ihr mich rollen?
ist doch noch mehr, ich hör doch was
ich hör doch was hier
ok, ist alles dead
bleib mal ein bisschen im
Busch und spotte
ja, über die
Range, oh da kommt ein Auto
oh
what the
fuck it
also jetzt ist ja
Leute, es ist gut
ist gut
was haben die denn hier oben
gerade rauf gehauen, haben die irgendwie
5 AC-130s oder
sowas gehabt in der Ecke
die erste Base ist schwer zu halten
shit
so und da kommt jetzt jede Menge runter
nice, oh
fuck
fucking hell
wie die Engländer dazu teilweise sagen
die sagen gar nicht fucking, die sagen
fucking, fucking
ich weiß auch nicht wie ich da drauf komme
zumindest, zumindest manche
Dialekte
oh oh
woah, woah, woah
woah, woah, woah, moment, moment
wo ist mein Smoke, Smoke Launcher
ok, dead, dead
au, lass mich in Ruhe
man, geh weg, geh weg
geh weg, ich renn in den Smoke rein
leg mich hin, kann mir nichts passieren
easy dodged, easy dodged
jetzt hab ich halt
einen Smoke zwischen mir und dem
fuck it
shit
ah
ok, wenn wir Glück
haben, wenn wir Glück haben, können
wir, nice
hätte ich gar nicht
gedacht, wo, wo, wo stellst
denn hier was überhaupt
so, von hinten kommt
nichts mehr, da oben, da oben
da oben ist der Ultrastellser
guck mal, ich seh ihn, ich seh ihn
aber der weiß nicht, dass ich da bin, hoffe ich
alter, lass mich rauf
game, please, please, game
game, ich hoffe
da sieht mich keiner
das war zwar PP geaimt as fuck, aber
ich glaub, wir haben alles
oh man, nein
ok, wir müssen da ran
ich hab's probiert, Leute
hey, den hatten wir eben im Team, den Typ
ich, ich
hab's, ich hab's probiert
keine Chance, dead kill
ja, es ist
nicht möglich, Katze vergessen, ja
so, jetzt, die Base geht besser
die Base geht besser, wobei, wenn man nicht schnell
da ist, überrennen die das Instant
man muss nämlich sagen, man hat unten, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es seht
man hat unten jetzt einen Sekunden-Counter
was ich nicht gut finde
weil es jedem daher gelaufenen Noob
anzeigt, wann er über die Grenze laufen konnte
bei den alten Rush-Maps oder
in den alten Spielen, da musstest du das
Timing so ein bisschen
im Gefühl haben oder halt einen Timer laufen
lassen, dass ein Timer runterläuft
ist eigentlich, eigentlich ziemlich
blöde, es wäre
Rock, wenn er, wenn es resetet
ok, nice
ok, wenig Glück
wo ist der hin?
in den Busch, oder?
alter
ok, dachte, dachte, der ist noch nicht dead
oh, oh, da ist einer
äh, Heap, ich
versuch dich zu holen, ich probier's jetzt einfach mal
es kann durchaus sein, dass ich jetzt gleich
richtig von der Seite weg sniped werde
ok, es war eine schlechte Idee
fuck it
die Gegner sind schon recht geil auf uns
gerade
what the heck, wie viele kommen da gerade um
oh, nice, nice, nice, nice
pass mal auf Max, ich hol dich, ich hol dich
ich ignorier einfach
alle Gegner und hoffe, die sehen mich nicht
nein
what, seht ihr, wie das durchfliegt
seht ihr, seriously, wie das durchfliegt
die Schütze gerade, habt ihr das gesehen?
shit, shit, shit
yep
ist der tot, Max, da hinten?
ich glaube
nicht sicher, ok
ich hab keine Ahnung
ich baller da einfach mal rein
ich mach noch mehr Smoke
scheiß drauf
shit, ich hab ver-aimed, fuck it
aber nice
niceer Versuch, kommt nicht auf die Idee
mich zu retzen, Leute, das kann ja knicken
ok
ich geh mal kurz beim M-Com rein
man weiß ja nie
ja, nö
oh, oh, oh, was ist da oben mit dem?
das ist manchmal echt
Pepega-Time, aber wenn ich Glück habe
ich glaube, ihr kriegt mich hier relativ safe
nice, danke
die reiben sich hier
komplett auf, das ist nice
das ist richtig gut
guck mal, die haben kaum noch
Tickets und sind nicht mal richtig, oder?
oh
ganz schlechte Sache
da müssen wir hin
da müssen wir hin, die machen jetzt
shit
die sind fast tot
äh, ich hab Schiss
ein bisschen, so, gerade
fuck
nein, ich hab dem auch noch die Tür aufgemacht
ich wollte eigentlich
in den Container rein
die haben geplantet, Alter
kennt noch jemand?
der das gesagt hat, geplantet
könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern?
dass der Friseur mal ein Video hochgeladen hat
von jemand, der Banana Planter hieß
und danach hat sich rausgestellt
so eine Sniper-Montage
der hat gecheatet, as fuck
naja, kann sich keiner mehr dran erinnern
das ist zwölf Jahre her
woher wollt ihr das wissen, ja?
aber, nur so
so, Member Berries
nix da, ich seh nix
haben wir die, okay, ich glaub
wir haben die komplett
ja
war das nicht
das war MW3, ja? MW3 Sniper-Montage
oder sowas war das
aber gut gemacht
ich hoffe, wir sind Top Squad
wieder
Crispy hat's ein bisschen runtergezogen
vielleicht, aber kann ja nicht
jeder
High-Performer-Crime-Set-Mindset
haben
immer noch in dem Game
mal ganz davon abgesehen, ich bin froh über jeden, der das noch spielt
dass ich ein bisschen Value
aus dem Kauf krieg, das hab ich gar nicht geguckt
waren wir Top Squad, oder nicht?
ach, ich kann im Stream
nee, Mist, Stream ist schon vorbei
okay, gibt's jetzt G36?
nee
ach, Moment
Leute, seht ihr mal, was ich
für eine Loop bin, man unlockt das erst
wenn man den Battle Pass
fertig hat
nee, oder?
ich bin's
ich hab modernes Gaming
doch, ist so
ich hab modernes Gaming noch nicht verstanden
ich weiß nicht mal, wie
Battle Passes funktionieren, oder?
das sollte alles sein, wenn die Punkte voll sind
Erika Haber
kriegen die meisten nicht hin
als Attacker
in Battlefield 2042
wir sind Attacker
entweder erste Base
Instant, oder
wir reiben uns auf
wollen wir dafür vielleicht
nicht lieber
das hat ja schon
relativ große Range
nee, wir bleiben bei der ACR
das Ding ist gut
ich hätt gern ein Auto
nein, nicht diese hässliche Drohne, Alter
Auto
excellent
so geht das, Leute
wenn die wegfahren
so muss man's machen
der ist seriously stehen geblieben
ich glaub's nicht
ja, fahr, fahr
ey, Leute, was ist mit euch los, man
was ist mit den
PP-Guys los
das heißt Rush
warum heißt es Rush?
weil man rushen soll
und das sieht dann so aus
und jetzt ist man dead
aber der Gegner auch
aber immerhin hat man gerusht
da kommt's drauf an
so, vielleicht kann ich bei meinen Leuten rein spawnen
fuck, meine Leute sind auch dead
ok
oh, oh, wir haben geplantet, nice
Massive Firefight Planting Action
aber die defusen schon
ok, vielleicht haben wir Glück und kommen da rum
taugt dir das Game mittlerweile halbwegs
für ab und zu mal so
zwei, drei Stunden ist es ok
ansonsten
würde ich kein Geld
ausgeben
ok, jetzt wird's
advanced, jetzt wird's anspruchsvoll
ich hoffe, die haben mich einfach noch nicht gesehen
jetzt wird's
oh, shit, shit, da sind mir ein bisschen viele
pass mal auf, pass mal auf
ich hab's verkackt
die hätte ich haben müssen
hätte ich die beiden gehabt, hätte ich weitergehen können
blöd gemacht
Max, spielst du eigentlich alleine?
nee, gerade nicht, gerade sind wir hier mit drei Leuten am Start
ich bin gerade unschuldig, wo ich gespawnt bin
wo bin ich gespawnt?
ok, YOLO
what the?
ok, Max
oh, shit
nein, shit
hätte funktionieren können
wahrscheinlich hätte ich echt noch mehr
killen sollen
wir schlagen uns
besser als 90%
der
actual
wir schlagen uns besser als 90%
der Arica Harbor Attacker
die man normalerweise so sieht
wir sind in dem Game
also wir sind
shit, shit, shit
fuck, alter
jawoll, rein Leute, rein Leute
defusen jetzt, rein, rein, rein, rein, rein
lege Hände, lege Hände
jawoll, oh
der Heimdaler
alles klar
wie genau ging das durch die Wand?
perfekt, perfekt, perfekt Leute
Boris
gib, ich hol dich
leicht stressig
so
ein wenig stressig
ok, Bock
nice
wow
Leute, das ist richtig gut gewesen
dass wir die erste Base
bekommen haben, 90% der
Attackerrunden kriegen das nicht auf die Reihe
die Base zu holen
ähm
du kommst mit der Youtube Welt nicht klar
ey, wenn du als Zuschauer schon mit der Youtube Welt
nicht klarkommst
Game, come on
come on, habt ihr gesehen wieder
wie es durchgeflogen ist?
Leute, ich brauche jetzt dieses komische Meme
first shot missed
second, clearly
not aimed, ihr wisst was ich mein
und die Panzer LMGs
sind kacke
was soll ich, ey, was soll ich sagen
wenn du mit 32 als Zuschauer nicht klarkommst
ich bin fast 39, 39 jähriger
Boomer
ha
achso, das ist einer von mir
klar, dankeschön Game, sehr gut
excellent
habt ihr, ihr habt bestimmt sofort gesehen, dass das
dass das einer von
meinen Teammates war
ok, ich gehe mal raus
hier und versuche mal zu ruschen
wow
ich muss mal ein bisschen weiter außen rum
sonst wird das nichts, ich habe keine Sicht
ok, wenn die jetzt da oben drinnen
sitzen, bin ich ziemlich gefickt, aber ich probiere es mal
es sieht
nicht so aus
ich glaube in BC2 konnte man gar nicht
so weit hier runter
ist auf jeden Fall gut
ok, ich muss mal
in ein Haus rein
ok, ich dachte vielleicht ist hier irgendein Gegner drinnen
ne, ist nicht, ok, hier ist sehr gute
sehr gute Spawn Position
für meine Dudes
ihr wisst hoffentlich nicht wo ich bin, ne
ihr solltet
keinen Plan haben, wo ich bin
hoffe ich mal
jetzt, jetzt könntet ihr es vielleicht
ah ja, ah ja, was ist hier
alter, seriously
ich habe ein Problem, Leute
ah, Boris
Pepega Boris
hinter mir ist irgendwas, ich muss mal kurz hier hoch
ich weiß nicht, wo die hin sind
ah, ok
nice
nice, ok
jetzt können wir gleich ein bisschen pushen
ich glaube, aber hier unten ist einer
bin mir nicht sicher, wow, Pants Man
der Pants Man
ok, pass mal auf
ich bin mir nicht sicher, oh da war was
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher von wo
der kommt
nice
ok, Respawn, Pog, Respawn, sehr gut
ich habe
Schiss, ich habe Schiss da raus zu gucken
ich mache mal ein bisschen
Spawn Beacon, lebendes
Spawn Beacon für meine Leute
oh, shit
Pants Man ist da
ok
nein, da war doch
das waren doch meine Mates
ich dachte
das war blau, also meine Mates
sehr gut, da unten ist ein Medic
oh, ihr seid nice, nice Teammates
deswegen gewinnen wir auch
hoffe ich mal
ok
YOLO, YOLO, auf den Balkon
oh, Alter
weg hier vom Fenster
ok, nice, nice, nice
ich sehe da rechts ganz viel
ok, jetzt können wir langsam
vorpushen, die Base ist viel
viel schwerer als gedacht
da unten ist
noch einer drin an B
ok, ich push B, nice
ok, B, B, B
sehr gut, sehr gut
ey, das ist ja
brutal anstrengend
das ist halbes ESL
Final hier wieder
ich camp mir hier einen ab, Leute
ich gehe hier nicht raus
bis das Ding detonated ist
wenn jetzt einer von links kommt, habe ich gelitten
oh, oh, oh
gleich ist es weg
Boris
wieder zurück
ok, nice
nice
nice, nice, gleich haben wir es
wir sind zu viele im Haus
wir sind zu viele im Haus, wir sollten raus
und selbst wenn wir sterben
wir müssen einfach nur ein bisschen gucken, wo die sind
ok
da konnte man aus der Entfernung alles mit dem
Carl Gustav klein machen, das ist richtig
Carl Gustav war sehr OP im WC2
das war die Geburtsstunde
von no RPG on in
fucking noob
falls
sich
jemand
remembert
ja, ist klar, Game
was
ist hier noch was
Chetkis
nee, oder
ok, jetzt müssen wir
Trick 17 um die Ecke
ja, ok, ich wusste nicht, dass da oben
noch einer ist, fuck
der Bernd hat mich gekillt
welcher Bernd
Prokoli Bernd
das nimmt mich jetzt schon ein bisschen mit
von Prokoli Bernd
geownt zu werden
schon äußerst deprimierend
dann würdet ihr
gerne von Prokoli Bernd gebasht werden
denke ich noch nicht
ist der noch da
nee, ich glaube nicht
null Recoil, nee
man muss tap schießen, dann geht das
Tepke
einfach ein wenig
ach Boris
aua
oh shit
ja, nice
ok, ich habe nichts mehr gesehen
es war mir zu viel, aber wenn ich Glück habe
meine Leute sind ja ziemlich
six head
nee, dead
schade
also du kannst es natürlich nach unten ziehen
die haben das ja aber gepatcht, guck mal, ich zeig dir das mal
also, du sollst jetzt eigentlich
so schießen
beziehungsweise, das verbackt, das resettet sich nicht mehr
du kannst relativ easy
runterziehen, also Recoil ist nicht problematisch
also ziehst du einfach nach unten, da bleibst du gleich
aber du triffst halt nicht mehr
warum ist der Recoil Hammer so
ultraschwer für Attacker
das ist wirklich
heftig gerade, wir sollten
hier unten lang stelzen
wo ist mein Team, oh, nice
Teamgewehr ist ja schon voll weit
exquisite Team
excellent, excellent
vielleicht, vielleicht können wir hier unten ein bisschen was abfahren
hier ist nichts, aber wenn wir Glück haben
wenn wir Glück haben
oh shit
warum laufen die in dem Moment hoch, wo ich den
Gigachat flank mache
very sad
oh, oh, nicht sterben
nicht sterben, nein, nein, nein, nein
jetzt hört mal auf, immer
dort zu sein, wo ich nicht hingucke
aber wenn ich Glück habe, kann ich geretzt werden
geht das?
oh, nice
ok, pass mal auf
zweiter Gigachat flank
Bernd, Bernd
wieder am Start
oh shit, shit, shit, shit
Max, ich hol dich
oh nein, Max, ich bin an dir vorbeigestellt
du stirbst jetzt doch nicht, halt
ich wusste gar nicht, dass sie deutsch redet
shit
nicht gesehen
Leute, lasst mich lieber spawnen, ich versuch mir nicht zu retzen
Jawoll, Jawoll, Jawoll, sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut
oh, oh shit
jeep
oh, Giga
Giga Noob Aim
ich hab ihn auch um die Ecke gucken sehen
also, muss sagen
an unserem Team liegt es ja wirklich mal wieder nicht
an uns
an uns liegt es wirklich wieder nicht
muss man so klar
formulieren
aber jetzt haben wir vielleicht eine Chance
oh shit, oh shit
Max, Max, ich hol dich
ich mach jetzt YOLO
nein, nein, nein, nein
Max, hab ich noch gekriegt?
ging nicht, oder?
what, Alter
wo bin ich hier, wo lande ich hier gerade
ne, es war mega close, aber
ich hätte ich fast gekriegt
ok
werfen wir uns gerade einfach nur random
noch auf die Gegner drauf
ich muss aber erstmal alles smoken
hier
ok, da gehen wir jetzt rein
da gehen wir rein
ich seh nix, ich seh nix, ich seh absolut gar nix
die müssen ja eigentlich von da kommen
oder von da
aber wahrscheinlich eher von da, da ist doch schon der erste
hier
au
ok
nice, wir haben es
jawoll
Erika Haber ist auch immer anstrengend für Attacker
muss man echt sagen, also
da gibt's nix
das ist wirklich nur für
absolute attacking Gigachats hier zu gewinnen
äh
ich dachte da ist irgendwas, aber
anscheinend nicht
äh, nein, du
das war Melonen
Paul
das ist so wie so ein random generated
Xbox, Xbox Live
Gamertag
hier, du bist doch Medic, Medic, Medic
Poggers Medic
High IQ Medic
Matze, jawoll
keine Tickets verschwenden hier
keine Tickets
depleten
wow, wow, wow, ich muss weg
da ist gerade direkt ein RPG unter mir durchgezischt
oh, das ist FJ
den kenn ich, der ist richtig gut
den hab ich auch schon gespielt, der ist on stream
ok
push, push
oh Mist, ist es zu hier?
Gigachat
Aim wieder am Start gewesen, habt ihr es gesehen?
einfach nur absolute Gigachat
Aim
ich camp mir hier einen ab
ich camp mir jetzt hier richtig einen ab
sobald die pushen
sobald die pushen, sind sie dead
ich glaub die kommen von links
gut, gut
Max, ich hol dich
huh, ok, da drüben war irgendwas
pass mal auf, wir machen mal hier
wow
Broccoli Bernd
diesmal nicht Broccoli Bernd
alter
ganz schön viel, ganz schön viel
oh, oh, veraimt
ich sag euch, der Typ ist gut
also der ist wirklich nicht verkehrt
mit dem hab ich schon gespielt, der macht immer richtig, richtig nice Runden
kann der mal sterben?
ok, pushe, pushe, pushe
ach, wir brauchen noch was
ich kann loop
ich dachte, ok, Achtung, Achtung
nein
hier kommt gleich was, hier kommt gleich was
ok, ok, volle Pulle ran
jetzt hier
so muss es sein, lege Hänne
lege Hänne
bip, bip, bip, bip, bip
jawoll
jetzt geht es durch hier
nix da
ok, wo kommen die Defender?
nicht, nicht gut geaimt
aber gut geaimt complanted
nice, next please
Max, ich hol, ah, du bist schon
bist da, nice
ok, also Erika Haber, Leute
ich sag euch
das kann ich nicht oft mit meinen 38 Jahren spielen
da krieg ich
da krieg ich Durchball
Erika Haber Attacker
andere können das vielleicht den ganzen Tag
aber ich krieg das nicht hin
aber gute Runde bis jetzt, oder?
mein 45.13, kannste nicht beschweren
ah, Mist, dead
die Runde nehm ich einfach
ich mach morgen ein Battlefield
Season 5 Fazit Video
nehm ich einfach die Runde
und gut ist, ist auch lang genug
hieb, ich hol dich
oh, oh, oh, ich glaub wir sind dead gleich
uh
die Runde früher und wir wären wirklich dead gewesen
ja, das ist so
so easy lass ich mich auch nicht schieben
Praxisse
da zahlt sichs aus, wenn man einfach mal ein bisschen
Aimlab gemacht hat
dann ist man nämlich direkt drauf und die sind dead
äh, ok
oh, schlechte Idee zu reloaden
ich hab ein bisschen Schiss
ehrlich gesagt gerade
da raus zu gehen
weil das so viele, oh, oh, oh
Max, ich kann dich nicht retten, Max, probier mal mit zu spawnen
falls die dich nicht kriegen
die Gegner
stellen sich aber auch gerade an
und wir haben
gelegt, sehr schön, sehr schön, sehr nice
von rechts
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
von wo
ok, da, ich komm hier nicht raus
ich würd ja gerne ein bisschen vorpushen
da, oh, oh, oh, oh
schön
schön in die Fresse
oh, da hatte ich aber mehr Glück
als Verstand, dass der sich nicht umgedreht hat
ok, sind da Gegner?
Gegner, Gegner
ich muss gucken, wir müssen gucken, dass wir die
Spawns abfangen
shit, shit, shit, shit
ok, ich versuch mal
ich versuch mal zu
unsere Leuten zu helfen
ich will auch nur mal sicher gehen, dass das durchkommt
sitze, sitze, schon ist die Fuse ge
schon ist die Fuse ge
oh, what the hell
hat er mich shotgun gerade?
hat er mich gerade shotgun?
ja, er hat mich shotgun
ich war ja so schnell dead
ok, jetzt wird es echt noch mal close
das letzte zu erwischen
fuck
nein, nein, nein, er retzt mich nicht, Maxi
der steht direkt unten
ok, der
alter, die sind
jetzt sind sie aber, jetzt sind sie aber scharf
die Gegner, ja
und wir sind dead, ok
ob wir das noch mal hinkriegen?
wir haben Panzer
übrigens dieser Granatwerfer, ne
das ist, das ist so
so ein Schrott
ich geh raus, ich geh raus
Broccoli Bernd
shit
oh, veraimt
wir können es schaffen, wir können es schaffen
wir sind fast dran, wir sind fast dran
vielleicht, vielleicht hab ich Glück und irgendjemand
ne, ich spawn, ich spawn draußen rein, das ist besser
wir sollten noch genug Tickets haben
für das Reinspawn
nice, nice, nice
ok, und jetzt
einfach abcampen
jetzt einfach nur
einfach nur abcampen
die Stairs
weiß nicht genau von wo, aber ok
einfach nur die Stairs abcampen
shit, dachte ich mir, dass der Typ
von da anrückt, aber komm
der muss jetzt sterben, Leute, ihr seid 50
50 Spieler auf dieser fucking Bombe
und jetzt defust einer
ne
oh, Smokes, du hast recht gehabt
meine Güte, ey
alter, war das anstrengend
so, und wenn wir jetzt nicht
Topsquad sind, Leute
dann ist Uninstall
was hat Max immer mit dem
Topsquad, ja, warum nicht
wenn man, wenn man gecarried hat, muss man
auch Squad, ja, first place
sein, aber nice Runde
mein Hirn
hat zwischendurch ausgesetzt, das ist
nicht mehr
nicht mehr möglich gewesen, ja
Heap hat richtig gehackt
oh
MonkaW, Leute
ja, Heap, wenn du willst
war nice, kannst nächstes Mal wieder mit Pounden mitspielen
guter Helipilot ist immer
ultra nice to have
da ist man nicht so abhängig davon
dass die Runden halt
gut laufen, wo es Helis gibt
lohnt sich das Game nun zu spielen
lohnt sich das Game nun zu spielen, also
wenn du schon gekauft hast, auf jeden Fall
zu wieder reingucken
wenn du es im Sale kriegst
und Battlefield magst, denke ich schon
wenn du den
Pass hast, auf jeden Fall
ansonsten, also ja
prinzipiell schon, auch wenn es
immer noch ultra verbuggt ist und irgendwie noch auf
Live-Support ist, aber es gibt halt nichts vergleichbares
so richtig
aber nicht zum Vollpreis
gar keinen Fall zum Vollpreis, ansonsten
wenn du es irgendwie ein bisschen billiger kriegst, oder
kannst ja auch mal gucken, ob du bei irgendeinem
Key-Shop deiner Wahl was für
5€ kriegst oder so, dann kann man dich kaufen
ja dann
dann spielt es auf jeden Fall wieder
es ist jetzt für Leute, die das Spiel gekauft haben
wirklich die beste Zeit nochmal
reinzugucken, weil das ist
wahrscheinlich die vorletzte
Season, wenn überhaupt, ja also
wer weiß, was bei 6 nochmal
kommen wird, ob wie viel das ist
ob es eine 7. gibt, mal schauen
also jetzt nochmal reinzuschauen, ist
auf jeden Fall sehr sinnvoll, wenn du es
eh schon gekauft hast, so viele Spieler wie
jetzt, hast du halt wieder eine Weile nicht
bis zur nächsten Season, und die nächste Season kommt halt
irgendwann im Oktober, oder so
die Release-Zyklen für das Game sind halt richtig
Massives, das PP-Ger
richtig
naja, feels sadgeman
aber zumindest ein bisschen
sein Geld kann man da noch rausbekommen
ich mein, ich hab jetzt am Ende, wie viel
Playtime hab ich?
sieht man das irgendwo? guck mal, ich mein
immerhin, 110 Stunden jetzt
normalerweise hätte ich jetzt irgendwie
2000 oder so, wenn es ein geiles
Battlefield gewesen wäre, weil ich das seit eineinhalb Jahren
nonstop gespielt hätte
aber immerhin, ich mein
110 Stunden, das ist seine
Playtime vom Geld her so
er ist jetzt fast wieder raus, ja
wobei man halt sagen muss, Playtime
zu Geld ist eh eine ziemlich bescheuerte
ähm, ja, so
Verhältnis, weil
es kann auch kurze Spiele geben, die
mega geil sind, das Geld einfach wert waren
oder Sachen, die man 1000 Stunden
gegrindet hatten, dann feststellt, man wurde nur
abgefuckt, also, ja
aber ich denk, das ist schon ganz okay
wenn man, also die 110 Stunden
für den Preis
ingame ging nicht, weil du offline
geschaltet bist, aber es hat doch funktioniert
mit reinjoinen, warum ging es denn dann auf einmal?
muss man das verstehen?
denke nicht
ach, du bist über den Max?
ha
ja, das kann sein, aber ich hab dich doch invited
das müsste doch auch gehen, wenn ich offline bin
aber die Gründe von
DICE sind
unergründlich, ne
kann das schon sein, dass es daran liegt
ja, bei ihm ging der Invite
instant, was auch immer
hinterfragt das einfach nicht
Battlefield-Logik
und da kannst du dir nix dran ändern
okay, Leute, wir sehen uns die Tage
nächster Stream, nächstes Youtube-Video
bis denn, macht's gut, see you